PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. COLLEGE EYES
FOR THE SLIGHT DELAY IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS. ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT SIX ONE ZERO. ONE
EIGHT FIVE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. FOR
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENTS YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. BE
ADVISED THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE UN MUTED AND
YOU ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. AND
PLEASE WATCH THE USE OF YOUR
BUDS. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEES WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. ARDINGLY EACH SIDE
WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A TOTAL
OF THREE MINUTES ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
BE MANY MAINTAINING DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING-SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WELL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND TO CONDUCT UR HEARINGS IN
AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. SO PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL. AND PLEASE BE
PATIENT SO THAT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES MAY BE HEARD. WE HAVE
NINE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX SENATE
BILL ONE OH TWO BY SENDER
MELENDEZ. HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
THIS HEARING. THERE ARE THREE
MEASURES PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
IDMS TO SB FOUR OH SEVEN FOUR
SB FOUR ONE FOUR AND EIGHT S.
B. FOUR ZERO ONE. BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO PLEASE REMIND YOU
TO TURN YOUR MICROPHONE ON ROTH.
ROTH HERE MELENDEZ HERE
MELENDEZ HERE ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA HERE ÎTS
HERE BACK- HERE BAKER HERE DODD.
DODD HERE EGGMAN HERE EGGMAN
HERE HER TADO JONES LEYVA YOUR
LEYVA HERE MEN HERE MAIN HERE
NEWMAN. NEWMAN HERE AND SHOW
ABOUT- HERE A SHOW ABOUT HERE
PAN HERE HERE AND HERE. BERMAN
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED MEMBERS WE
WILL NOW TAKE UP OUR CONSENT
FILE IS THERE A MOTION. SO
MOVED MOVED BY SENATOR LEYVA
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION ON THE CONSENT FILE IS
DO YOU PASS. TO APPROPRIATIONS-
AND FILE ITEMS Q. AS BEFORE-
SEVEN ARCHULETA FILE ITEMS FILE
ITEM FOR SB FOUR ONE FOUR JONES
FILE ITEM EIGHT SB FOUR OH ONE
HE CAN. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
RALPH HI ROTH HI MELENDEZ HI
MELENDEZ HI ARCHULETA BURCHILL
OUT I'D BE FLYING HE BEAT HI
BACKER. BACKER AG DODD ALL DODD
AYE EGGMAN HI. HEY I HEARD.
JONES LEYVA. HI LEAVE A AYE MAN
AYE MAN AYE NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN
AYE AYE CHAU ABODE HI A SHOW
ABOUT A GUY PAN HI CAN I.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT. IT'S
TWELVE ZERO LET'S- KEEP THIS
MATTER OPEN IN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS IN CASE OTHER MEMBERS-
ARE ABLE TO BREAK THREE FREE
FROM THEIR OTHER OBLIGATIONS
AND JOIN US. CIRCULAR YOU HAVE
ONE BILL TO PRESENT TODAY SB
THREE OR FOUR. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN ROTH AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING. I'M HERE
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE
ALL FOUR HANDY PERSON EXEMPTION
UPDATE. SENATE BILL THREE OH
FOR UPDATES THE VALUE OF MINOR
WORK CONSTRUCTION CONTRACT NOT
SUBJECT TO REGULATION BY THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSING
BOARD FROM FIVE HUNDRED TO ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. THE
CONTRACTORS LICENSING BOARD THE
WASHINGTON REGULATES
CONTRACTORS AND HOME
IMPROVEMENT SALES PERSON. UNDER
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSING LAW.
CONTRACTORS UNDER THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE THE
LAW MUST MEET SPECIFIED
REQUIREMENTS AND MAINTAIN A
CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE WHICH CAN
SOMETIMES REPRESENT A HURDLE TO
WORK. THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSING BOARD CURRENTLY
ALLOWS HANDY PERSONS TO BE
UNLICENSED AND STILL PERFORM
CONSTRUCTION WORK AS LONG AS
THE COST OF THE WORK IS UNDER
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. AND IS
CONSIDERED OF CASUAL MINOR OR
INCONSEQUENTIAL NATURE. THIS
EXEMPTION ALLOWS CONSUMERS
ACCESS TO UNLICENSED ANY PERSON
TO PERFORM MINOR CONSTRUCTION
JOBS WHICH SAVES CONSUMERS TIME
AND MONEY IT ALSO CREATES.
INCREASE JOB ACCESS FOR UNDER
LICENSE AND THE PERSONS
HOWEVER. THE LAST UPDATE TO
THIS EXEMPTION WAS IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. WITH SENATE BILL
TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN- O'CONNELL
WHEN THE THRESHOLD WAS RAISED
FROM THREE HUNDRED TO FIVE
HUNDRED. THE VALUE OF FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS WORTH OF
CONSTRUCTION WORK IS NO LONGER
WORTH THE SAME AS IT WAS IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. THIS
CREATES SEVERE LIMITATIONS FOR
UNLICENSED HANDY PERSONS AS
PRICE FOR MATERIAL AND LABOR
HAVE INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY.
IN THE PAST TWENTY THREE YEARS.
SENATE BILL THREE OR FOUR WILL
INCREASE THE THRESHOLD OF THE
EXEMPTION FOR UNLICENSED
CONSTRUCTION WORK AS LONG AS
THE WORK IS CONSIDERED CASUAL
MINOR INCONSEQUENTIAL FROM FIVE
HUNDRED TO ONE THOUSAND
INCREASING. CONSUMERS SAVE TIME
AND MONEY ON SMALL PROJECTS. I
HAVE COMMITTED TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS OR AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS THEY MAY
HAVE AND A PLAN TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
TODAY I HAVE ANA BOX
REPRESENTING THE BILL'S SPONSOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. THANK YOU AT I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU THE PROPER
TIENEN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ARRIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER
WILL NOW MOVES TO THE TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL FROM
YOURKEY SUPPORTERS- MISBACH.
GOOD MORNING MEDICARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR
ME- PLEASE PROCEED. EXCELLENT
MY NAME IS ANNA BACK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA OF REALTORS
WE ARE THE FONG THIRD BUT AT
THE THREE OH FOUR WHAT DOES THE
SENATOR DID PLAIN WILL HAVE
EFFECT OF REYES THE LIMIT ON
WHAT IS KNOWN AS THE QUOTE YOU
NEED MAN EXCEPT IN THE LAW.
WHICH ALLOWED FOR UNDER WORKERS
TO COMPLETE VERY SMALL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS WITH A
COMBINED BECAUSE OF LABOR AND
MATERIALS NOT A. FIVE HUNDRED.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THE
FIVE DOLLAR ABOUT NOT BEEN FOR
THE PAST ONE THREE YEARS
DESPITE CONSTRUCTION. GREATLY
INCREASE OVER THE TIME. UNDER
EXISTING LAW THE WORK MUCH ALSO
BE OF A- CASUAL MINOR OR INCOME.
NATURE THIS BILL. RAISE THE
CURRENT OUT AND INADEQUATE FIVE
DOLLARS YOU THOUSAND. IF THAT'S
WHETHER ENACTED NINETEEN SEVEN
SEVEN WHEN THE BUDGET. O THAT
AN EXEMPTION FOR LICENSE WORK
WHAT THE PROPER. THAT LITTLE
BUT IF YOU HUNDRED. ANY OF
THREE DOLLARS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY. LAKE IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT THE LETTER REPAIR THE AND
RAISED IT TO THE FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS WHERE STILL TODAY. IT
IS WELL NO THAT COSTS AND CAL.
HAVE WRITTEN YOUR IN RECENT.
FAR EXCESS OF THE GENERAL RATE
IN. OR SO BECAUSE OF LIVING
INCREASE. AN INCREASE FROM
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO ONE
THOUSAND. IS BOTH OVER. AND IT
IS TIME STILL ADDED. HELP FOR
THE TWENTY YEAR THE
SKYROCKETING LABOR AND
MATERIALS. IN THE CONSTRUCTION
FIELD. NOT EVERY HAS THE WAY
WITH ALL TO BECOME A LIFE
CURRENT CAL. ESPECIALLY WERE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY. NOT
EVERYONE HAS THE PROTECTION OF
POWERFUL IN. IF THE THEM IN
THEIR SKILLS A LIVE. AT THE SO
CALLED HERE THE PEOPLE HAVE A
RIGHT TO EXIST. AND SUPPORT
THEM SO WITH A LIVING. AND TO
PROVIDE SERVICE TO THEIR. OR
THE OTHER TO MAKE A BLANK STATE.
THAT THOSE DOING WITH A LIE
INCLUDING ALTHOUGH THESE ARE
COMMUNITIES ARE POTENTIALLY.
THE ELDERLY IT'S DIFFICULT
DEPLORABLE IN MY OPINION. IN AS
THE CSW ONE DOLLAR VERY FEW IF
ANY OF THE NOT LIFE AND BE
COMPLETE. COMFORT COMPLAINTS
ABOUT WORKER WORKING THE LAW.
THE SEATTLE BE I. NATURALLY
HAVE THAT MANY HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS SIMPLY CANNOT
AFFORD HANDY PERSON IS ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES AT CHEAPER
RATES. THE LESS FORTUNATE I'M
NOT NECESSARY TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD UP HERE KEEP OUR HOME.
WE REALLY WANT TO DISCOURAGE
LANDLORDS FROM HAVING MINOR
ISSUES FOR THEIR TENANTS
ADDRESS. BECAUSE OF DOING THAT.
AND LIVING. HAS CONTINUED TO
RISE EACH YEAR WELL THE VALUE
OF IT FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT
HANDY PEOPLE CAN START FOR A
JOB. INCLUDING LABOR AND
MATERIALS. HE WROTE IS
THEREFORE JUSTIFIED TODAY THAT
THE STATUTE BE ADJUSTED AGAIN
THE COUNT FOR. BOTH INFLATION
AND THE INCREASED COSTS IN
CONSTRUCTION MATERIAL. WHICH
VERY OFTEN OUTPACES INFLATION.
HOLDING CONTRACTORS LICENSE IS
A PRIVILEGE NOT REQUIRED BOTH
WHERE IT'S CALLED AN
INSIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
OVERHEAD. TO MAINTAIN THIS
LICENSE. THERE ARE MANY
WORKERS. THAT WORK AT HANDY
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE
SKILLS THEY WANT TO PUT TO YOU.
EARN A LIVING I CONTRIBUTE. OUR
ECONOMY BUT NOT THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THE
WHEREWITHAL OR THE FINANCES
NEEDED YOU GET AND MAINTAIN.
THESE LICENSES. I THREE OPEL
THREE THREE THREE CALIBER THE
OF THIS. HE PAYS CITY CON.
AIRPORT WE ASK FOR YOU I. TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AS BUCKLEY
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESS HERE IN
THE GALA INTO. OF BILL THREE IS
FOUR. I SEE NO WITH STAND ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISH TO IN SOME OF
SENATE THREE ZERO FOUR. I SEE
NO SUCH WITNESSES THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY. VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING OF HIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
OF FOUR WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU MEDICARE WILL NOW- START BY
INVITING THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THAT TIME. PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
AND WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE
TWENTY NINE. YES GOOD MORNING
CAN YOU HEAR ME. ONE TWENTY
NINE WHEN YOU CALL IN THE IN
OPPOSITION OR IN SUPPORT- AND
OPPOSITION. OKAY BUT IT'S A
GOOD OF REMOVE YOUR LINE RIGHT
NOW UNTIL WE WERE READY FOR A
POSITION AT THE MOMENT. AND
AGAIN RIGHT NOW- AS PER THE
BUDGET CHAIR OF THE CALL WE ARE
ONLY TAKING THOSE WHO ARE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT AT THE TIME.
I'M GOING TO GO TO ONE FORTY
FIVE. MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
CATAMARAN WITH- AND RENEW
SOCIUS REPRESENTING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. FINE PINE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN RON AND THE
VICE CHAIRPERSON MELENDEZ THIS
IS KEPT ON WITH THE AMERICAN
SUBCONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION AN
ORGANIZATION COMPRISED OF UNION
AND MARRIAGE JAPANESE. I'M SURE
SOME OF YOU HAVE HAD MINOR WORK
IN THE LAST YEAR AND CERTAINLY
THE FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR LIMIT
IS ALMOST A QUARTER OF A
CENTURY OLD AND THEN AFTER THAT
ACCIDENT- I PERSONALLY OBSERVED
COUNTY. QUALIFY YEAH AND- FOUND
ONE PERSON TO. THAT REMOVE. AND
THAT I PAID NINE HUNDRED NINETY
FOUR DOLLARS YEAH. HE WHICH IS
ANCHORED THE BILL OVER A
THOUSAND. A LITTLE UNITED
STATES AND SMALL JOB VERY AS WE-
THIS YEAR AND THEN AFTER. ALLOW
SMALL HEY JOBS BECOME. THE BILL
IS VERY APPROPRIATE AND
CONSUMERS WILL GREATLY BENEFIT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
LET ME REMIND THE- WITNESSES
SEEKING TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE LEVINE
THAT YOUR. COMMENTS NEED TO BE
VERY VERY BRIEF- THEORETICALLY
NAME- IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
BUT- I'LL PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
MORE FLEXIBILITY BUT THEY HAVE
TO BE BRIEF NEXT TO MR
MODERATOR. MISTER CHAIR WE HAD
NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. HAVING HEARD FROM ALL OF
THE- SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM OPPOSITION. LET'S
CHECK THE GALLERY ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY WE
HAVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING WE HAVE-
AND HANG ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL AS OUR FIRST
WITNESS. IS THAT YOU MA'AM THAT
IS ME PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU-
GOOD MORNING US SENATOR ROTH
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS ERIN LEHANE I APPEAR
BEFORE YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
NEARLY HALF A MILLION MEMBERS
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL. OF
CALIFORNIA- THE BILL TODAY IS
SEEKING TO INCREASE THE LIMIT
BY A FULL HUNDRED PERCENT-
WHICH IS A PRETTY BIG JUMP- IF
THE- YOU KNOW THE CENTER OF
THIS THIS DISCUSSION IT SEEMS
TO BE. A LACK OF APPRECIATION
FOR THE AMOUNT OF SKILL AND
TRAINING. IT TAKES TO BE A
CONSTRUCTION WORKER- IN ALL DUE
RESPECT I DON'T THINK THERE IS
A CASUAL OF CONSTRUCTION WORK-
JUST AS THOUGH I DON'T THINK
THERE IS CASUAL- PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE OR- MYSELF BEING A
LICENSED LAWYER THE PRACTICE OF
LAW OR EVEN BEING A CASUAL.
REALTOR THIS IS- A PROFESSIONAL
DOES IN FACT TAKE WHERE WITH
ALL IT TAKES WHERE WITH ALL OF
TRAINING. IT TAKES WHERE WITH
LL OF UNDERSTANDING INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS IT TAKES THE WHERE
WITH ALL OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION. TO PROTECT BOTH
WORKERS AS WELL AS HOMEOWNERS
WHO MAY HAVE THESE- UNLICENSED
CONTRACTORS INTO THEIR HOME- SO
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF WHERE WITH
ALL- THIS. BILL WILL CHURN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY- AND THERE
ARE. A LOT OF WORKERS TODAY WHO
WILL WORK FOR FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS CASH. TO DO SOMETHING
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
TRAINING OR THE EXPERIENCE TO
DO. THEY'LL BE DOUBLE THAT
AMOUNT OF WORKERS WHO WILL BE
WILLING TO WORK FOR A THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN CASH. TO DO THINGS
THAT THEY HAVE. NOT THE SKILL
SET FOR OR THE EXPERIENCE TO
DO- THIS WILL JUST DOUBLE. THE
ACCESS TO THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY TO EXPLOIT WORKERS AND
TO EXPLOIT JOB SITES- IS A
COMFORTABLE DOUBLE
CALIFORNIANS. THERE ARE REPORTS
AFTER THE PHONE- THE
DEVASTATING FIRES IN LAKE
COUNTY. OF UNLICENSED
CONTRACTORS. WHO ARE TRAINED
UPON VICTIMS OF THE WILDFIRES-
THIS IS THE TYPE OF THING. THAT
THIS THRESHOLD- SEEKS TO
PREVENT. A CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS AGAINST. WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING IS MAKING SURE.
ALL WORKERS WHO ARE DOING
CONSTRUCTION. ARE INSURED ARE
TRAINED TO FOR THE PROTECTION
OF EVERYBODY. BECAUSE WE HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO PROTECT THE
HOMEOWNERS. THE WORKERS AND TO
DISCOURAGE THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THIS MORNING. THANK YOU
MA'AM. ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SENATE BILL
OKAY SIR PLEASE TAKE THE MIKE.
STATE YOUR NAME PLEASE. AND
YOUR FILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION. OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES. WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OTHER WITNESSES IN THEGALLERY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SENATE BILL. SEEING NONE LETS
GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SENATE BILL THREE ZERO FOUR.
SEEING NONE LET'S NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL THREE ZERO FOUR WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND AGAIN THIS IS FOR PEOPLE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. YOU CAN PRESS ONE
MIN ZERO THE JOIN THE QUEUE
RIGHT NOW. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE THIRTEEN LINE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE INTER
AMERICA'S PRESIDENT OF THE
NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA
BUILDING TRADES. ON BEHALF OF
OUR THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS IN THE
NORTHEASTERN PART OF CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING VICTIMS OF THE
CAMPFIRE IN THE CAR FIRE.
PLEASE STAND IN VEHEMENT
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE OH FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. LINE. TWENTY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING- COMMITTEE- CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ROBERT SMITH AND THE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY SIX AND
WE STAND WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES AND- BUT- POSING. BILL
STOP THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY.
THANK YOU SIR LINE FIFTY KO. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CRISTINA ALARCON
BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF BOILERMAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT FIND.
FIFTY ONE. FOR EVERYONE MY NAME
IS JOHNNY TEACHER NATALIE
PETERS NOT CHANGED HIS ACCOUNT
OF THIRTY SIX ON THE APPLE
WATCH AND OTHER MEMBERS AND
SEVEN CALIFORNIA WE ALSO OPPOSE
SB THREE OH FOUR THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE NEXT. LINE.
TWENTY NINE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS TOMMY
ABOVE I EVER PRISON IBEW LOCAL
ELEVEN LOS ANGELES UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY IS STILL RAMPANT
PROBLEM HERE IN LOS ANGELES-
WITH THE USE OF THE NON
LICENSED CONTRACTORS THERE IS
NO OPEN LEVEL PLAIN FAILED-
RESPONSIBLE CONTRACTORS
CONSUMERS AND WORKERS- GETS
HURT BY THIS- TYPE OF- PROGRAM-
WITH THESE IMPORTANT REASONS
THAT WE OPPOSE S. B. OH FOUR
AND- JUNE TO VOTE NO. NEXT PINE.
SEVENTEEN GOOD MORNING- SENATOR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS AN ESTIMATE ON WHAT THE
LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY
IS BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL REPRESENTING ONE
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND HARD
WORKING WAGE EARNERS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION SECTOR AND IAM
CALLING TO VEHEMENTLY URGE YOU
TO OPPOSE- THIS BILL AS IT WILL
CONTINUE TO- THE TURRET THE JOB
QUALITY AND CREATE. MORE RACIAL
INEQUALITY IN THE RED
CONSTRUCTION. THANK YOU NEXT.
LINE THIRTY EIGHT. MORNING
MONEY IS MICHAEL WITH COUNCIL
SIXTEEN NOW TRADE AND WE WITH
BUILDING AND ARE OFTEN ABOUT
THREE THREE OR FOUR. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NINE TWO FIVE. I
AM NAME IS DANIEL MEANT YOUR
AND I AM SENIOR PHILIP THE CAL
CAR REACH COUNCIL FOR COUNTY TO
FRESNO MADERA KING INTEL THERE
ARE OF PORTRAY HIMSELF HAND IN
ANY MANNER UNDER AND JELLY MY
ANY OF INSURANCE ANGLE BONTA SB
THREE OH WOULD GO THE THREE FOR
THIS ACT IN PLACES CLIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY SENIOR
CITIZENS AT RISK OF LIABILITY
AND FINANCIAL. ANALYSIS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
PLEASE. LINE. FIFTEEN GOOD
MORNING SHERRY COMMITTEE
MARTELLA TORY REPRESENT THE
CARPENTERS UNION LOCAL FORTY
SIX LOCAL NINETY ONE NINE LOOK
AT SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE
SACRAMENTO YOLO COLUSA YUBA
SUTTER ALTERADO PLASTER SEER
ALPINE IN ABOUT A COUNTIES AND
AT THE GRILL FOR PROMOTING THE
CLASSIFICATION OF WORKERS AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS LEAVING
THEM WITHOUT CRUCIAL WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS OF THE RIGHT
MINIMUM WAGE ACCESS TO PAID
SICK LEAVE DISABILITY INSURANCE
AND UNEMPLOYMENT SERVICE. WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THRILLED FOR.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. SURE NO
ONE ELSE COULD SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
CHECK THE LINE ONE MORE TIME TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
ALL WITNESSES- WITH RESPECT TO
THIS PARTICULAR BILL SENATE
BILL THREE ZERO FOUR. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS IS
THE FINAL CALL IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. WITH REGARD TO THIS BILL
RIGHT NOW PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. THE
STRUCTURE WE HAVE AT LEAST TWO
PEOPLE WHO SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT
PLACE. GOING TO GO TO LINE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL FIVE HIDDEN PROPERTIES
LEADERS. WHEN UP CLOSE THANK
YOU. LINE. NINETEEN YES GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS CESAR VARGAS
TEAMSTERS LOCAL NINETY SIX- SO
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THREE OR
FOUR- THIS BILL WOULD DECREASE
STANDARD CENTER CENTRAL
PROTECTIONS INFRASTRUCTURE-
TEAMSTERS STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
NEXT PLEASE. THE TEACHER THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HELP SIR. IN FACT
THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WITNESSES WHO
PROVIDED TESTIMONY TODAY WILL
NOW BRING IT BACK TO A
DISCUSSION HERE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR WITH MY COLLEAGUES
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- SENATOR PAN. BUT I
CANNABIS CHAIR- AND- FREESHEET
THE PRESENTATION FROM THE BILL
AUTHORED BY DID HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL- FIRST
OF ALL- I UNDERSTAND UNDER
EXISTING LAWS SAID WORK MUST BE
CONSIDERED QUOTE CASUAL MINOR
OR INCONSEQUENTIAL AND I
REALIZE THAT'S EXISTING LAW.
BUT CAN YOU CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION SO FOR EXAMPLE SAYS
RAISING THE THRESHOLD FROM FIVE
HUNDRED TO A THOUSAND IS
PROPOSED IN THIS. BILL. IF YOU
KNOW THOUSAND DOLLARS I MEAN
FOR EXAMPLE IS THIS INCLUDE
PLUMBING OR ELECTRICAL WORKS-
H. FAX SYSTEMS SOME OF THESE
CAN BE FAIRLY. TECHNICAL AND-
IF THEY'RE NOT DONE RIGHT-%
AGAIN SOMEONE. HERE WOULDN'T
WOULDN'T HAVE TO HAVE A
CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE SO CAN YOU
JUST CLARIFY THE DEFINITION OF
CASUAL MINOR INCONSEQUENTIAL
DOES THAT INCLUDE- WORK THAT
WOULD. INVOLVE- THINGS LIKE
WITH THE PLUMBING ELECTRICAL
AGE BACK THOSE TYPES OF THINGS-
THE THINGS WERE THERE'S NOTHING
CONSEQUENCES IT'S NOT DONE
RIGHT. THE FUTURE BUT I WILL
ENSURE FOR A LITTLE BIT THEN
I'LL ASK OUR OUR A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS TO JUMP IN. BUT IT IS
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
POINT THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT-
IS ALL WORK WHETHER BE
ELECTRICAL PLUMBING HEATING
ROOFING- ANYTHING TO DO. WITH
CONSTRUCTION IT COULD NOT
EXCEED THEONE THOUSAND DOLLAR
THRESHOLD- WITHOUT OF A
CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE AND
BELIEVE ME I AM AN HOTEL YOU
TOTALLY SUPPORT OF THE UNIONS
THE WORKERS EVERYONE AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THOSE WHO ARE
DOING THE CONSTRUCTION WHETHER
IT BE FIRE REPAIRS OR ANY
CONSTRUCTION THEY SHOULD ALL BE
PROTECTED ALL THE WORKERS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MINOR WORK. THAT
THE HOMEOWNER IS ABLE TO PICK
UP THE PHONE AND GET THE
NEIGHBORHOOD HANDY PERSON TO DO
THE WORK AND AGAIN AS A
REMINDER THAT THE WORK IN
QUESTION IF IT IS VIOLATED- AND
IT EXCEEDS THE AMOUNT THERE'S A
SIX OUT OF SIX MONTHS. IT'S A
MISDEMEANOR WITH THAT WOULD
CALL FOR SIX MONTHS IN JAIL A
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE AND-
IT IS OVERSEEN BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LICENSING
BOARD- WHO HAS THE JURISDICTION
TO DO THAT. BUT- ALL THE WORK
WE'RE TALKING TO. NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. TO TODAY- SO THAT
IT'S A NUMBERS GAME HERE IT'S
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS WHICH IS A
THOUSAND. SO IF I'M ASKING TO
TAKE THIS OUT OF COMMITTEE SO
THEY COULD CONTINUE-
NEGOTIATING BECAUSE THERE IS
ROOM FOR NEGOTIATION THE FIND
THAT READ THAT MAGIC NUMBER
BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED. AND ONE
THOUSAND IF IT'S SO AGREED UPON
AND I THINK THE SPIRIT OF LABOR
HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO NEGOTIATE.
TO FIND THE RIGHT NUMBER ACROSS
THE BOARD AND I THINK THIS IS
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO IS GET IT
INTO THE NEXT COMMITTEE SO WE
CAN CONTINUE. LOOKING FOR THE
AMENDMENT BUT I WOULD LIKE- THE
SPONSOR TO JUMP IN THE FALL
THERE'S ANY COMMENT TO THE
QUESTION. OR MAYBE I MY OTHER
QUESTIONS AND WHETHER THE
SPONSORS WANT TO ALSO ADDRESS
THE AS WELL SIX CRISTINA TARD
TO BRING PEOPLE ON THE LINE OR
THEY CAN ANSWER RIGHT NOW USE
SUCCEED. YEAH OKAY EXCELLENT SO
THE PARTS A WIN SO ONE QUESTION
WAS ABOUT THE TYPE OF WORK AND
APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWER AND
WE'LL HEAR FROM THE SPONSORS AS
WELL. THE SECOND QUESTION IS
ACTUALLY RELATED TO YEAH IF
YOU'RE NOT IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
LICENSE- THE LICENSE REQUIRES
YOU TO BE FUNDED REQUIRES THE
OF WORKERS COMPENSATION SO. IS
SO HAS TO DO AGAIN- WITH THE
RISK. TO THE HOMEOWNER WHO ARE
THE PERSON WHO INVOLVES THIS
UNLICENSED CONTRACTOR WHETHER-
AND I REALIZE THAT THEY'RE
STILL AT RISK. UNDER FIVE
HUNDRED BUT- IN TERMS OF THE
HANDYMAN GETS INJURED ON THE
JOB WHAT'S THE LIABILITIES AND
TO THE PERSON ENGAGING THEM.
ESPECIALLY NOW THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT POTENTIALLY MORE
SUBSTANTIAL WORK AND THEN
FINALLY. I GUESS THE OTHER
QUESTION IS THAT- USED.TO TALK
AND A PREVIOUS CENTER ACTUALLY
TALK ABOUT NEGOTIATION BUT WHY
A THOUSAND- THE INFLATION WOULD
HAVE CAPS WOULD HAVE PUT IT
LOOKS LIKE ACCORDING TO THE
ANALYSIS AROUND EIGHT HUNDRED
SO. THE REASON FOR ACTUALLY.
THIS IS YOU MENTIONED SHE ASIAN
WHAT WHY DOUBLE ITS SYDNEY A
MORE. WITH WHAT THE INCREASE
WOULD HAVE BEEN. FOR SO THE
QUESTIONS IF YOU WISH TO. AB
SPONSORS ANSWER THEM- OR S. U.
S. ANY FURTHER ANYTHING FURTHER-
SERDULA FEEDING AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ANSWERING THOSE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU I THINK
YOUR YOUR YOUR POINT. IS WELL
TAKEN IF THE INFLATION RATE IS
APPROXIMATELY HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
DOLLARS AND- EIGHTY SEVEN CENTS
WHY ISN'T THAT THE NUMBER. OF
LET THE- SPONSOR ENSURE THAT-
BUT GOING BACK TO THE
PROTECTION OF THE WORKER.
OBVIOUSLY THE JOBS THAT ARE
DONE ARE DONE BY. HOMEOWNERS
WHICH HAVE HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE. WHICH DOES PROTECT.
THE HOMEOWNER AND THE WORKER
GOD FORBID IF SOMETHING WERE TO
HAPPEN ON THE PROPERTY. SO THAT
IS HOW THE PROTECTION IS THERE
DOESN'T ELIMINATE THAT.
PROTECTION IT JUST ALL WE'RE
LOOKING FOR. IS THE FINDING THE
RIGHT NUMBER SHOW UP. IN A BOOK
WOULD YOU PLEASE- JUMP IN. YES
GOOD MORNING- STARTING OFF WITH
REGARD TO WHY THE ONE THOUSAND
DOLLAR NUMBER WELL THAT'S
SIMPLE THE COST OF LIVING AND
DOING BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
HAS CONTINUED TO RISE EACH YEAR
AND THAT FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
NOT THAT SAME FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN ADDITION WE HAVE
SEEN HUGE INCREASES IN
CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS. THAT
ARE FAR OUTPACING THE CARBON
INFLATION FOR EXAMPLE DR
AUTHORED BY THE REASON YOU'RE
COULD BE 30% ANNUAL INCREASES
AND PACKING A WALLOP NOTHING I
HAD THE PERSON WOULD VERY WELL
BE INTERESTED IN DOING SO WELL
AND GRAYSON STAYS AROUND 2% A
YEAR WE'D BE TALKING MATERIALS
GOING WAY WAY THAT AS WELL AS
THE COST OF LABOR I'M- ALSO
WITH REGARD TO THE DEFINITION
OF WHAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED
HANDYMAN WORK THAT LANGUAGE-
CASUAL MINOR OR INCONSEQUENTIAL
NATURE. EXISTS IN FACT YOU AND
THERE IS ACTUALLY THERE'S NOT A
DEFINITION OF- WHAT IT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED CASUAL MINOR
INCONSEQUENTIAL WE'D BE OPEN TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION ON
HI AND REFINING THAT DEFINITION
SO WE CAN FIND THE RIGHT
BALANCE HERE- MOVED BACK THIS
BILL. FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SEVERAL OF SO ACTUALLY
THERE STOP THIS BRIEF- THAT
CITY. I HAVE TO AT THAT- ICE
HAVE A IT INTERNAL ADDRESS
CONCERN I SUING. YOUR DESIRE TO
WERE WITH THE OP. BUT I THINK
IT POINT TIME- NOT SURE I'M
REAL THERE THE- FOR ON THE BILL
BUT YOU THANK YOU SO PENSION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I
APPRECIATE HEARING THE AUTHOR
SAID THAT HE'D BE WILLING TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION I'M
GONNA LAY OFF TODAY IF THE BILL
GETS- TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE. I
HOPE THAT SOME OF THOSE THINGS
WILL GET WORKED OUT- I THINK
THAT THE ISSUE I HAVE IS IT
KIND OF PUTS A CRACK. IN THE
FOUNDATION NO PUN INTENDED- AND
THEN THERE ARE SOME KIND OF
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT SO THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO LABOR. CENTER.
MELINDA'S PAUL BY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- SO IF I
HAVE A OF THE BILL AUTHORED I
MAY- IS THERE ANY LEGAL
RECOURSE FOR SOMEONE GIVEN THE
SITUATION IF THERE'S- YOU KNOW
THE WORK ISN'T DONE PROPERLY
THE CONSUMERS NOT SATISFIED
SHOULD THIS BILL PASS WOULD
CONSUMERS STILL HAVE SOME SORT
OF LEGAL RECOURSE TO RECOUP
THOSE COSTS OR HAVE THE PERSON
FIX THE PROBLEM YES AND-
SENATOR DO WHAT THE WAY IT
WORKS OBVIOUSLY AGAIN LET ME
STATE THIS AT THE INFRACTION.
IS THERE AN AND THE BEEN IT'S
DISCOVERED THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
CHARGE TOO MUCH- AGAIN IT'S A
MISDEMEANOR SIX MONTHS IN JAIL
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE IN
ITS OVERSEEN BY THE STATE
CONTRACTORS LICENSING OARD AND
BECAUSE WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT
A NUMBER THAT IS BENEATH AT A
THOUSAND DOLLARS THE- THE
RESTITUTION OR OR THE MONEY IS
RETURNED WILL COME FROM SMALL
CLAIMS COURT. BETWEEN THE
HOMEOWNER AND THAT AND THE
PERSON SO- THE HOMEOWNER IS
PROTECTED BY LAW USING THE
COURT SYSTEM BECAUSE OF THE
FACT THAT IT IT'S UNDER A
THOUSAND DOLLARS HE IN-
EVERYONE'S BEEN PROTECTED AND
THAT'S THE POINT THE CONSUMER
WHO HAS THE OPTION AND IN AGAIN
WITH ALL THE CONSTRUCTION THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN THE
FUTURE. AND YES WE NEED TO
PROTECT OUR OUR CONTRACTORS IN
THE AND THE UNION WORKERS AND
WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT AND
AGAIN THIS IS JUST THAT SMALL
ELEMENT IN IN AGAIN REMEMBER
THIS IS MATERIAL AND LABOR SO
IF YOU HAVE MATERIAL THAT'S A-
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS AND
THEIR CHARGE FOR THE WORK IS
GOING TO BE THREE OR FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT EXCEEDS IT
SO A CONTRACTOR MUST BE
OBTAINED IN THAT'S THE ISSUE
IT'S JUST THE COST AND IT'S GOT
TO BE AN ADJUSTMENT. AND AS WE
pHEARD- FROM THE SPONSOR. THAT
THEY'RE READY TO SIT DOWN AND
CAN CAN YOU TRYING TO FOR THAT
MATCH NUMBER IN THE WHY WE'RE
JUST TRYING. GET IT TO THE NEXT.
I THANK YOU FOR THE ANSWER THAT
CLEARS THINGS UP I THINK ON MY
END AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT- THIS. THE AGGREGATE
AGGREGATE CONTACT. CONTRACT
PRICE HASN'T INCREASED IN
TWENTY THREE YEARS A NUMBER OF
CST- HAVE INCREASED IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST TWENTY
THREE YEARS IN THE LEGISLATURE
HAS SEEN FIT. TO MAKE SURE
THAT- PAYMENT MATCHES THE
RISING COSTS FOR INSTANCE THE
MINIMUM WAGE- WE CONTINUE TO
RAISE THE MINIMUM WAGE BECAUSE
THE COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA HAS INCREASED OVER
TIME. AND I'M NOT SURE THAT
THERE'S- A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. THE RISE IN THE COST OF
MATERIALS THE RISE IN THE COST
OF LABOR. MEAN FOR I'M JUST
THINKING BACK TO WHEN. AROUND
FENCE BLEW OVER IN OUR YARD.
AND THE COST HAD SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASED FOR THE MATERIALS TO
REPLACE THAT. NOT BECAUSE OF
THE PERSON CHOOSING TO DO THE
WORK JUST BECAUSE OF THE
MARKETPLACE SO IT INCREASES.
THE COST AND THAT THAT'S NOT
YOU KNOW ANYBODY'S FAULT IT'S
THOSE ARE JUST THE FACTS. SO
THE COST HAVE INCREASED IN.
TWENTY THREE YEAR TIMES I JUST
WOULD CHALLENGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO FIND. SOMETHING THAT IS
WITHIN THEIR POWER TO
INCREASED. THE- IN. THE COST
FOR SOMEONE TO RETURN TO RECOUP
THAT THEY HAVEN'T YOU KNOW
INCREASED IT IN OTHER WORDS WE
TAKE THESE OPPORTUNITIES ALL
THE TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT.
IT'S COSTING REVENUE ARE OUR-
MATCH SO I FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL I DON'T THINK THAT RAISING
IT TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS IS.
INAPPROPRIATE IN THE LEAST BIT
FRANKLY I SHOULD PROBABLY- BE
HIGHER BUT I THINK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
TODAY AND I THINK YOU FOR.
STANDING UP FOR ALL THE PEOPLE
OUT THERE WHO ARE TRYING TO DO
THESE JOBS IN BELIEVE ME
THERE'S PLENTY OF ROOM FOR
LICENSE CONTRACTORS IN THE
STATE TO DO ALL THE WORK THAT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING AND THEN
SOME. NOBODY'S GETTING EDGED
OUT THERE'S PLENTY OF ROOM FOR
EVERYBODY TO OPERATE IN THIS
SPACE SAID THANK YOU. AND I
MIGHT ADD SENATOR FROM A- THE-
THAT. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS HAS
ALWAYS SAID TO EVERYONE ALWAYS
TRY TO GET THREE BIDS WHETHER
IT'S A TERMITE WORK WHETHER ITS
TITLE COMPANIES LOANS- THE
THREE THE MAGIC THREE A BOOK
GETTING BIDS TO HOMEOWNERS AND
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE SCENARIO.
WHERE THE REALTOR TELLSTHE
POTENTIAL HOME SELLERS THAT YOU
NEED TO DO THIS THIS AND THIS
AND- THE BEST THING TO DO IS
GET SOME BIDS AND OF COURSE IN
SOME CASES THEY WILL START WITH
THE HANDY PERSON BUT THEN WHEN
THEY REALIZE THAT IT'S GOT TO
GET UP INTO FAR EXCEEDING THE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. THEN IT HAS
TO BE THE LICENSE CONTRACTOR
AND THIS IS WHERE THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IS
PROTECTED THIS IS WHERE THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS PROTECTED
BECAUSE THEN YES INDEED THAT
WOULD BE SOMEONE WITH THE
LICENSE AND AGAIN AS I SAID
EARLIER THIS IS PLUMBING
HEATING ELECTRICAL ROOFING- AIR
CONDITIONING TERMITE WORK YOU
NAME IT- IF IT EXCEEDS THAT
NUMBER IT'S GOT TO BE A
LICENSED CONTRACTOR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR QUESTION THANK YOU OF
CENTER MELINDA'S OF CINNAMON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I SHARE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF MY
COLLEAGUES SENATOR- I
APPRECIATE THE- PURPOSE OF YOUR
BILL BUT- I DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT- LESS THAN QUALIFIED
FOLKS WORKING ON ON THINGS AND
I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
CONTRACTOR CONTRACTOR FRAUD- IN
A REPORT THAT YOU I THINK YOU
SAW THIS YEAR'S STILL BEING
NOTED THAT. THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF COMPLAINTS
RECEIVED FROM CONSUMERS FOR IN
THE SPACE OF FIVE HUNDRED FIVE
THOUSAND. I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
MORE DATA I THINK I'M GONNA
ECHO CENTER LAVERS STANCE I I'D
THEM YOU KNOW I KNOW YOU'RE AN
HONORABLE PERSON- I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING HOW YOUR
AMENDMENTS PROCEED- SO I'M
GONNA STAND TODAY AND SEE WHAT
THE FINAL PRODUCT LOOKS LIKE. I
THINK IT'S AN CINNAMON THANK
YOU CENTER. THANK YOU MISTER SO
TO ECHO SENTIMENTS COMMENTS AND
CENTER LATEST. BUT ALSO TO
GENERAL AND HIS POINT THAT YOU
KNOW AS TO THE RECOURSE FOR THE
CONSUMER. AND SMALL CLAIMS
COURT THINK AS WE ALL KNOW IT'S
NOT A PARTICULAR EFFECTIVE
VENUE FOR RECOUPING. THE COST
PARTICULARLY AROUND THIS CLASS
OF CONTRACTORS THAT YOU DAY-
JERRY DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
THEY ARE HARD TO FIND. I'M NOT
SURE THAT'S A GOOD REMEDY- AND
TO MY MIND THE BIG ISSUE ON%
THIS BILL IS AROUND THE RATHER
AMBIGUOUS DESCRIPTION OF THE
WORK A CASUAL MINOR. OR
INCIDENTAL- I THINK CENTER
MELINDA'S POINT ABOUT THE
FENCE. IS WELL TAKEN- SO MY
QUESTION TO OTHERS HAS SOME
THOUGHT BEEN GIVEN. TO BETTER
ARTICULATE PARAMUS AS TO WHAT
CONSTITUTES.CASUAL OR
INCIDENTAL WORK AS OPPOSED TO
THE KIND OF BLANCA PROVISION
RECEITA AND THAT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION CENTER. THE
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IS
WILLING TO GO AHEAD AND GET THE
DEFINITIONS. IN THE NEXT LEG OF-
THE COMMITTEES- NOT ONLY WITH
THE NUMBER THAT SENATOR PAT HAD
MENTIONED. THAT THE ADJUSTMENT
AND ALSO BUT THE DEFINITION SO
THERE'S WORK TO BE DONE. AND IN
ORDER TO GET THIS TO THE OTHER
SIDE. BUT THESE THINGS WILL BE
WORKED OUT. HOPEFULLY IN THE TO
COME TOGETHER. I'M SORRY I AM.
THAT SONORA ARE- BUT THAT'S BIG
CHANGE- THAT A COUNTY CHANGE-
BUT I WILL NOT BE SO. THIS IN
ITS PRESS FORM TODAY BUT I HOPE
WE CAN GET THAT IN FUTURE FOR
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS COLLEAGUES ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. LET ME UP FOR MINE.
BUT SENATOR. DODD THANK YOU.
ONE OF THE PUT A LIGHT ON YOUR
HEAD. IS NOT ENOUGH COLOR HERE
WELL WE'RE GETTING CLOSE. BY
RIVALING YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WELL I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES I THINK GIVEN THE
COST- THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX
OVER THE YEARS I THINK YOU'VE
GOT SOME THINGS YOU NEED TO
WORK OUT IN TERMS OF THAT. I DO
RESPECTFULLY SAY THAT I THINK
IT'S MUCH ADO ABOUT NOTHING THE
REALITY IS I'VE HAD BILLS IN
THIS HOUSE I TRIED TO THWART
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
BUT THIS ISN'T REALLY. WHERE WE
NEED TO- HEY YO TO BE DOING
THAT BECAUSE AT A THOUSAND
DOLLARS WE ARE REALLY NOT
CREATING A HUGE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY LET ME GIVE YOU A POINT
I JUST SOLD MY HOME TOOK TO BE
QUITE A WHILE TO DO IT DURING.
DURING COVERT. BUT IT WAS
RELEASED THAT MY REAL OR DID.
IT IF. IF YOU HAD TO WAIT FOR A
PLUMBER TO COME IN TO REPLACE.
A FAUCET THAT HAD A LEAKY
FAUCET THE YOU JUST HAVE TO GET
DONE VERY VERY QUICKLY. I MEAN
THE REALITY IS. THE WITH THE
LATEST ON THE CLOSE EVEN MORE
TO REPLACE FIXTURES ALL OVER
THE ELECTRICAL OUTLETS JUST.
THE- WANTING TO DRESS IT UP A
LITTLE BIT THEY DON'T LIKE THE
HARVEST GOLD OR WHATEVER THAT.
THE COLOR IS A NAY THE- WHOEVER
COMES IN TO TRY TO HELP YOU
SELL YOUR HOME SAYS IT NEEDS TO
BE ALL WHITE. TO HIRE A
CONTRACTOR IN THE THESE PEOPLE
PERFORM A SERVICE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT- I THINK WE
REALLY SHOULD BE DONE I'D LIKE
YOU TO WORK ON A HOT THAT
DEFINITION. I'D ALSO LIKE YOU
TO- WORK ON THE ABOUT THAT I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU IT WOULD BY THE WAY
IT WAS THE AVOCADO THAT GOT ME.
THE AVOCADO. CENTER BAKER.
THANKS I JUST WANTED TO KNOW TO
APPRECIATE DIFFERENCE MY
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND- I'VE HEARD FOR SOME
REALTORS- IT FROM MY DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT BUT AS I DID DISCUSS
WITH HIM AYE AYE AND CONCERN
ABOUT SOME OF THE BROADER
IMPACTS THE BILL I'VE HAD SOME
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH
UNLICENSED CONTRACTORS AND-
ALSO SYMPATHETIC TO THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE TRAINS
UNDER ABOUT THE UNDERGROUND-
KANEMI SO I I'M GONNA LAY OFF
THIS BILL BUT I'M OPEN TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH- THE
AUTHOR GOING FORWARD. KELLY'S
ANY OTHER SENATOR TULLOW. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT MIGHT GO
TO COLLEAGUE FROM THE NAPA- AT
THE NAPA STATED EARLIER I. THE
COST OF LIVING THE COST OF
MATERIALS HAS JUST GONE WAY WAY
TOO HIGH- WE OBVIOUSLY WORD FOR
WORD A TIME WHERE WE ARE IN
NEED OF HOUSING- IN NEED OF
REPAIRS- AND QUITE FRANKLY IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WE HAVE A
LOT OF UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE WHO.
DUNE SYSTEM THIS THIS AREA OF
WORK THAT ARE PART OF THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY I DON'T
THINK THEY WANT TO BE PART OF
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY BUT I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE
GET THEM TO NOT BE PART OF THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY. AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING. THIS THIS BILL
TODAY AND I'M HOPING THAT THE
AUTHOR CAN CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH AT OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS
THEIR YOU KNOW ANY ANY CONCERNS
AND ISSUES THAT THEY HAVE BUT
ALSO TO. KIND OF LOOK AT HOW.
WE CAN IMPROVE THE JUST I THINK
WE NEED TO IMPROVE THE
LICENSING OF. THAT THE SEARCH I
BELIEVE THAT IT TAKES FOUR
YEARS TO GET CONTRACTORS
LICENSE AND THAT'S- THAT'S A
VERY LONG TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER TYLER ANY
OTHER MIKES COLLEAGUES ANY
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. YOU KNOW I WILL- I'LL
GIVE YOU MY COMMENT AT THIS
POINT YOU KNOW IT. IT CERTAINLY
APPEARS THAT THE SMALL WORK
PROVISION. FOR HOMEOWNERS HAS
BEEN IN PLACE FOR DECADES
ACTUALLY WITHOUT ANY
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE AT LEAST
THAT I'VE HEARD. ABOUT FROM
LABOR FROM OUR CONSUMER
ADVOCATES FROM. ANYONE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SINCE THE
BUT THE SEVENTIES OR EIGHTIES-
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS- SMALL
WORK EXCEPTION- PROVISION. HAS
ANY VALUE IN IT APPARENTLY DOES
IF THERE'S NO SPIN NO
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE. AS THE
ANALYSIS NOTES IT'S A SIMPLE
INFLATION ADJUSTMENT. BRINGS
THIS THRESHOLD TO AT LEAST
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS IF NOT
PERHAPS MORE. SO I GUESS-
CENTER IF THIS BILL MOVES OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND MOVES
FURTHER THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE. I GUESS ONE THING
IS THAT ASK YOU TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE INFLATION ADJUSTMENT AND
PERHAPS BRING THE NUMBER A
LITTLE CLOSER TO WHAT TO A KIND
OF MISTS CITY IT SHOULD BE. A
GIVEN THE FACT THAT IT HAS NOT
BEEN ADJUSTED SINCE AS I RECALL
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. NUMBER
ONE AND NUMBER TWO TO THE
EXTENT THAT- YOUR SPONSOR VIEWS
THIS AS CENTRAL TO REAL ESTATE
TRANSACTIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PERHAPS YOU WOULD
CONSIDER TYING IS A LITTLE
CLOSER TO- THE PURCHASE AND
SALE OF REAL ESTATE AND REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTION ITSELF. I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSER
TO A- YES FOR SURE- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS- ALL ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES- EDUCATED SEE.
THIS IS A HEALTHY DEBATE IT'S
BEEN- A GOOD ROUND OF TALKS.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATED BUT I
WILL TELL YOU AS A REALTOR FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE TELL ALL THE
SELLERS IS TO DISCLOSE ANY
MATERIAL FACT. OR DEFECT THAT
MIGHT BE IN YOUR HOME. AND YOU
MUST OBTAIN AN INSPECTION IN
TODAY'S WORLD. BUT LISTEN TO
THIS BY A LICENSED CONTRACTOR.
TO MAKE A DILIGENT INSPECTION
OF THE SUBJECT PROPERTY. IN ANY
DEFECTS THAT FOUND. WILL BE
PRESENTED TO THE POTENTIAL
BUYER AND TO YOURSELF. TO
OBTAIN- THE WORK BY A LICENSED
CONTRACTOR. WHICH INCLUDES
PLUMBING HEATING ELECTRICAL
ROOFING AND TERMITE WORK. SO
THE FOUNDATION IS THERE. TO
BRING THE CONTRACTOR INTO THE
FOLD OF THE TRANSACTION. AND
THE OTHER THING IS THAT WE'VE
WE'VE HEARD THE COMMENTS ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF THE INFLATION.
AND AND I THINK THIS IS THE
SPIRIT THAT WE'RE GONNA SEE AS
WE MOVE THE BILL FORWARD. AND I
THINK THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT CAN'T COME TO FIX-
SOMETHING THAT'S MINOR. AND
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT ARE NEEDED
TO REPLACE THE ENTIRE ROOF OR
TO ADD A ROOM. AS YOU KNOW THE
INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW IT'S GOING
INTO GRANNY FLATS IN THE-
GARAGE EXTENSIONS AND SO ON. IN
THOSE ARE JOBS THAT ARE NEEDED-
BY LICENSED CONTRACTORS IN THE
CITY'S A MESS OF THE
MISCIBILITY THE WE REPRESENT.
THEY'RE GOING TO OVERSEE THAT
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'M
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF. IS THE
MINISTER PALLIPES ON WEEKENDS
HAVE INSPECTORS OUT THERE AND
FINDING THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ADDING ROOMS AND THINGS TO THE
BROOKS TO THEIR HOMES. WITHOUT
THAT CONTRACTOR WITHOUT THOSE
PERMITS. AND SO I'M TOTALLY IN
THE SPIRIT OF DOING THE RIGHT
THING AND- ARE YOU WORKERS. BUT
THIS IS THIS IS SOMETHING IS
JUST AS MINOR ADJUSTMENT THAT'S
ALL WE'RE LOOKING FOR AND
THAT'S WHY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
MOVING ON AND ASK FOR YOUR
IDOL. THANK YOU CENTER-ARCHULETA DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON SENATE BILL THREE ZERO FOUR.
SENATE MOVED BY SENATOR
MELENDEZ. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS I'D LIKE
TO REMIND YOU TO PLEASE HAVE
YOUR MICROPHONE ON. FILE ITEM
ONE SENATE BILL THREE ZERO FOUR
ARCHULETA MOTION IS DEEP PASSES
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RAW HI. ROTH AYE
MELENDEZ AYE. MELENDEZ AYE
ARCHULETA ON ARCHULETA I'D BEAT
HI. EIGHT FIVE BACKER. DODD I
DOTD AYE EGGMAN. HER TADO I HER
TADO ALRIGHT JONES HI JONES HI
LEYVA. MAN NEWMAN. A CHAU BOGUS
I A SHOW ABOUT A GUY HERE IN.
THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
CENTER LAYERED. SENATE BILL.
FIVE FOUR FOUR. SIR YOU MAY
PROCEED YEAH THE SORT OF THE
MARQUIS ON ON THERE FOR A BIT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING I'M HERE
TO PRESENT SB FIVE FORTY FOUR.
REQUIRES THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL TO ESTABLISH TESTING
STANDARDS BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE FOR ALL
SPECIFIED. CANNABIS COMPOUNDS
AND CONTAINMENT WHILE CANNABIS
PRODUCTS ARE SAFE AND
RIGOROUSLY TESTED. REGULATIONS
VERY IN TESTING STANDARDS AND
DEFINITIONS OF MATERIAL SUCH AS
PESTICIDES PATHOGENIC MOLDS
FUNGUS OR BACTERIA. OR UNCLEAR.
ESTABLISHING GREATER UNIFORMITY
AND TRANSPARENCY AROUND TESTING
REQUIREMENTS WILL MAKE CANNABIS
AND CANNABIS PRODUCTS SAFER FOR
ALL. CURRENTLY THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT FOR STANDARDIZED
TESTING OF CANNABIS PRODUCTS. A
LACK OF STANDARDISATION MEANS
THAT ONE BATCH CAN PRODUCE
INCONSISTENT RESULTS BETWEEN
AND EVEN WITHIN TESTING
FACILITIES. AS THE
CONVERSATIONS TO CONSOLIDATE
THE STATE'S OVERSIGHT OF THE
INDUSTRY HAPPENED THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS. IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS LIKE IN THIS BILL ARE
NOT LEFT BEHIND. HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FOUR OR
JOSIE ROBERTO WITH THE
ETHERIDGE BOTANICALS AND EDDIE
FRANCO WITH CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PERCENT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPHONE THANK YOU SENATOR
WITNESSES PLEASE PROCEED. P.
DOES THE RIVER TELL. P. EIGHTY
FRANCO. HE. HELLO OTHER
CHECKING WHEN WE CHECK FROM
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY HERE TO SUPPORT SENATE
BILL FIVE FOUR FOUR SEEING NO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY.
SENATOR SHOULD WE WAIT TO IN
ORDER TO LONGER OR PROCEED WITH
A TELEPHONE CONFERENCE SERVICE
I'M FINE WITH PROCEEDING. OKAY
LET'S CHECK WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FIVE
FOUR FOUR. THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE URBIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL FIVE FOUR FOUR. WE WILL
BEGIN. PARDON ME- MISTER CHAIR
UP TO YOU REPEAT THE NAMES OF
THE WITNESSES THAT YOU WOULD
CALL THE POLICY. IT'S JOSIE.
AND EDDIE FRANK. MR REPAIRED-
YOUR LINE IS OPEN START- HI
THIS IS JUDY REBEKAH. GOOD
MORNING I AM THE FEE FOR ETHICS
FOR AND SHARED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TO DRAW YOU IN COMMITTEE
EARLIER THANK YOU FOR ALL
DURING THE CELL. WHEN WE AFTER
TO CALL PLEADING. CULTIVATE
THEN. AND WE- TO HELLO WHAT
THEY'RE TO SHOWN ARE THAT THEY
ARE FACING BASEBALL ANSWER
CASTING. AND THIS IS WE'VE WITH
THE TECH LAB WERE NOT BETWEEN
LAST WEEK. BUT IT WAS ALSO
WITHIN THE LAST. SO WHILE I
COULD GIVE YOU SEVERAL EXAMPLES
WHY WE NEED STANDARDIZATION
PROTESTING I WILL TELL YOU ONE
THAT REALLY STANDS OUT TO ME
AND THIS IS A- TRUE STORY SO.
THERE'S A LADY I'D LIKE TO SEE
YOU TAKE A BATCH TO DO THE
TESTING AND IT GOES THROUGH A
VERY RIGOROUS NINETY PROC FOR
EXAMPLE YOU TAKE THE FLOWERS
THE RAW MATERIAL YOU TESTED FOR
POTENCY AND CONTAMINANTS THEN
YOU EXTRACTED YOU TAKE THAT
CONCENTRATE YOU TESTED AGAIN
FOR COUNTRIES AND CONTAMINANTS
AND THEN. YOU PUT IT INTO YOUR
PRODUCT YOU TESTED AGAIN ALL
UNDER OUR ANTI THIS IS A VERY
EXPENSIVE PROCESS THERE SHOULD
BE A STRAIGHT LINE IT SHOULD BE
THE SAME IT'S THE SAME FLOWER
EVERY TIME. AND THEN YOU HAVE
TO BY LAW ONCE YOU EVERYTHING
HOUSES YOU MUST THEN GO THROUGH
WHAT'S CALLED THE FINAL TESTING
THE THIRD PARTY THAT CANNOT BE
CHANGED AND WHAT HAPPENS IS YOU
DO EVERYTHING RIGHT YOUR LOVE
YOU GO TO THAT. FINAL TESTING
IN A FAILED. DO HAPPEN FOR
NUMBER REASONS IN A LOT OF
TIMES IT IN TURN AND IT'S A
LACK OF. FROM ONE THIRTY TO THE
NEXT GIVEN THE SAME CALL. COULD
BE A ERROR WITH THE MACHINE.
NOT CLEANING ALL SORTS OF BEING
WE'VE GOT. BUT WHAT HAPPENS IS
PERSON NOW THAT ENTERED. NOT TO
DESTROY THAT PASSAGE AND MORE
ON THAN NOT A ABOUT YOU KNOW
HOW OF THOUSANDS DOLLARS YOU'RE
OUT. IN THAT ONE CAN IT WAS A
PORN FIFTY DOLLARS. WHILE LARGE
TOWN MY BE ABLE TO TAKE THAT IN
THE CAN. AND TAKES OUT. ALL
BUSINESS CANNOT MET HER AND
GREATLY. BOB AND WHAT IT CAN AN
ART A SMALL DUTCH IT IS ABOUT A
HUNDRED DOLLAR WORTH FOR JUST
TO PUT IT FIRST. IT'S NO FEAT.
AND SO WE REALLY NEED IT'S BEEN
THREE YEARS NOW- EVERYBODY
ACROSS THE BOARD FROM
CULTIVATORS MANUFACTURERS AND
THE CHILDREN ARE ALL CRYING OUT.
FOR THIS ISSUE TO BE ADDRESSED
SO I REALLY THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AND I THANK YOU FOR
DROPPING AND- WE YOU TO VOTE I
THANK YOU FOR MUCH THANK YOU-
MISS FRANCO YOU A LONG. I AM
APPALLED FOR THAT YOU GO GOOD
CENTER ANY THOUGH IT CALIBER
ACADEMY INDUSTRY IS THAT THE-
ADDED MR OF MENTIONED ALL THE-
ALL I CAN'T. UNDER EXISTING LAW
BECAUSE IT. MIGHT. MUCH AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
SIR MR MODERATOR LET'S GO BACK
TO WITNESSES WAITING ON THE
TELEPROMPTERS THE CONFERENCE
LINE IF YOU COULD GIVE ME A
TOTAL NUMBER PLEASE. THE FUTURE
WE HAVE AT LEAST THREE- FOUR
LINES OF PEOPLE WISHING TO
SPEAK ABOUT THIS BILL. BUT
AGAIN WE NEED TO- JUST GOING TO
WELCOME YOU TO JOIN FOR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT. OF SB FIVE
FORTY FOUR. EACH PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO PLEASE PERSONALLY NOW GO.
TO LINE. THIRTY SEVEN. PARDON
ME WE HAD TROUBLE WITH THAT
PHONE LINES TO MOM GOING TO GO
TO LINE. FIFTY NINE. HI GOOD
MORNING ONE OPEN. THANK YOU
COULD MORE SHANE DOES ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA TEACHER PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE.
SIX EIGHT. GOOD MORNING BOB
DONNAN. HELLO WE CAN HEAR A LOT
OF PRETTY PROCEED. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS AND- LOVING LEGAL IT IS
LAW LONG OVERDUE THERE'S A LOT
OF. HE DEALING WITH THE TESTING
AND AS- SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT.
ONE SIXTY ONE. ALISHA PRE I'M
OF THE CANNABIS ISN'T AND
STRONG THANK YOU NOW. THE
TEACHER THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME FINE
LET'S SERVE FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCEDURE IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION FIRST WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION. TWO
SENATE BILL FIVE FOUR FOUR
SEEING NONE. LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE NOW
LET'S GO TO THE TELEPHONE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. AND
WITNESSES WAITING ON LINE TO
TESTIFY THERE MISTER MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
FIVE FOUR FOUR WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE INTEREST THIS TIME.
PRESS ONE MILLION ZERO.
HAPPENED TO CHAIR NO ONE IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. FINE LET'S ANOTHER WE
HEARD FOR WITNESSES WE WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FIRST CENTER EGGMAN.
I THINK YOU I JUST WANT TO I
THINK THE AUTHOR BRING THIS
FORWARD BOTH WORK ON SOMETHING
LIKE THIS TO HAVE PREVIOUSLY-
AND- AND I THINK BEING ABLE TO
STREAMLINE TESTING IT JUST
HELPS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THE UNDERGROUND. ECONOMY AND
THIS DOES NOT TAKE OVER SO I'D
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL. PERFECT
MEMBERS ANY OTHER QUESTION. OR
COMMENTS. WAVE YOUR HAND.
SEEING NONE CENTER LAYERED
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BY TO
US FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR ERROR WE HAVE A BUTLER
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR EGGMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
FIVE SENATE BILL FIVE FOUR FOUR
LAYERED YOU POSSUM RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROTH HI ROTH AYE MELENDEZ AYE
MELENDEZ AYE ARCHULETA ON
VIRGIL OUT I'D BE. BACKER BY
BECKER I'D DODD HI DODD HI. HI
EIGHT HI TADO. JONES HI JOE I
LEAVE. HI LEAVE AT ICEMAN. MAY
I KNEW HI NEWMAN AYE I CHOSE
BOGUE HI THAT SHOW ABOUT GUY HI
CAN I. THE BILL HAS TWELVE VOTE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT.
THANK SEVERAL. I SAW SENATOR
BURGESS BUT- IN THE ABSENCE OF.
SENATOR BURGESS SENATOR NEWMAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED.
SENATE-DISTRICT AND WILL. THIS
IS SENATE BILL THREE SIX TWO
ADAM SEVEN ON OUR AGENDA. YEAH
IS THAT THE PRESS YOU MAY
PRESENT FROM DESK AND SHALL DO
IT WOULD. WHY NOT TO GET DESK.
THANK HERE ONCE. MISTER CHAIR
INSTEAD- I'M HERE BEFORE YOU TO
ADD TO ON BEHALF OF S. THREE
TWO WHICH WOULD PROHIBIT THE
SALES OR OTHER PER SPACE
METRICS THAT WOULD COMPROMISE
YOUR INTERFERE WITH
PROFESSIONAL JUDGE OF LICENSE
PHARMACY. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS LICENSED PHARMACIST
EMPLOYED BY LARGE RETAILERS AND
GROCERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAVE
BEEN SOUNDING ALARMS ABOUT
ADVERSE WORKING CONDITIONS
WHICH ARE INCREASINGLY
UNDERMINING THEIR ABILITY TO
PROPERLY CARE FOR THEIR
PATIENTS OVER THE PAST DECADE
IN RESPONSE TO A CHRONIC
SHORTAGE OF PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS CALIFORNIA'S PRIME
PHARMACISTS HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
GO ABOVE AND BEYOND THEIR
ALREADY COMPLEX
RESPONSIBILITIES. IN ORDER TO
FILL GAPS CURRENTLY PLAGUING
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM OVER
THERE INTERVAL THE LEGISLATURE
HAS STEADILY EXPANDED THEIR
SCOPE OF PRACTICE TO ALLOW FOR
ADMINISTERING FLU SHOTS TO
PRESCRIBING PREP MEDICATIONS
PROVIDING TACKLE TOBACCO
CESSATION TWO POOLS DISPENSING
CONTRACEPTIVES AND SUPPLYING
LIFE SAVING OPIOID OVERDOSE
RESCUE PRODUCTS AS A
CONSEQUENCE CALIFORNIA'S
LICENSED PHARMACISTS ARE TODAY
WORKING FASTER FILLING MORE
ORDERS AND JUGGLING A WIDER
RANGE OF TASKS WITH FEWER STAFF
MEMBERS FRANKLY AT A PACE. THAT
MANY SAY IS NOT ONLY
UNSUSTAINABLE BUT JEOPARDIZES
PATIENT SAFETY IN THE TYPICAL
COURSE OF FILLING PRESCRIPTIONS
A LICENSED PHARMACIST WILL
CONTACT THE PRESCRIBING
PHYSICIAN TO CONFIRM CORRECT
DOSAGE CHECK FOR DRUG
INTERACTIONS ALLERGIC RESPONSES
COUNCIL AND EDUCATE PATIENTS
ABOUT HOW TO PROPERLY
ADMINISTER THEIR MEDICINES
ANSWER PATIENT QUESTIONS AND
ALLAY PATIENT FEARS. ADD TO
THAT THE STRAINS AND STRESSES
OF THE CURRENT PANDEMIC WITH
MOST PHARMACISTS NOW PROVIDING
KOPET NINETEEN VACCINATIONS TO
DEFEAT THE MOST CHALLENGING
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY FACING
CALIFORNIANS IN OVER A CENTURY.
WITH CALIFORNIA'S LICENSED
PHARMACIST FORCED TO JUGGLE SO
MANY IMPORTANT DETAIL ORIENTED
RESPONSIBILITIES IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON US THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
AS A WHOLE TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
PRIORITY AND FOCUS CAN REMAIN
PROVIDING THE HIGHEST POSSIBLE
STANDARDS OF PATIENT CARE
RECENT INDUSTRY TRENDS TOWARD-
TOWARD EVER LEANER STAFFING
HAVE HAVE RESULTED. PHARMACY
OFTEN FORCED TO LONGER.
SOMETIMES FOR AS LONG AS TWELVE
AND- WITHOUT A BREAK OR OTHER
KIND OF RELIEF MOREOVER AS
OWNERSHIP OF RETAIL PHARMACIES
AND PBMS HAS CONTINUE TO
CONSOLIDATE OVER TIME.
PHARMACISTS HAVE ALSO
INCREASINGLY FOUND THEMSELVES
SUBJECT TO CORPORATE DIRECTIVES
GEARED NOT TO THE OPTIMIZATION
OF PATIENT CARE. BUT TO THE
MAXIMIZATION OF SALES AND
PROFITS. AS ONE EXAMPLE. IN THE
COURSE OF RECENT REPORTING ON
THE INDUSTRY DOCUMENTS OBTAINED
BY THE L. A TIMES REVEALED
THAT CVS WORKERS ARE EXPECTED
TO ENROLL AT LEAST 40% OF
PATIENTS INTO THE COMPANY'S
AUTOMATIC. PRESCRIPTION RENEWAL
PROGRAM. THE PRESSURES
INFLICTED BY THE SORTS OF SALES
QUOTAS ON ALREADY OVERBURDENED
PHARMACIST INCREASES THE
LIKELIHOOD OF ERRORS LEADING TO
POTENTIALLY DEADLY MISTAKES.
EACH YEAR NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIA'S
EXPERIENCE HARM AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF UNINFORMED OR
IMPROPER USE OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS. WE NEED TO BRING THIS
NUMBER DOWN NOT ALLOW IT TO GO
UP FURTHER. PHARMACIST LIKE
DOCTORS MUST BE FREE TO
PRACTICE MEDICINE IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE ETHICAL DICTATES OF
THEIR PROFESSION. JUST AS WE
TAKE AN OATH OF SERVICE IN
ASSUMING OUR ROLE SO TO
PROFESSIONAL PHARMACISTS AND I
LIKE TO READ IT HERE. I PROMISE
TO DEVOTE MYSELF TO A LIFETIME
OF SERVICE TO OTHERS TO THE
PROFESSION OF PHARMACY IN
FULFILLING THIS BOW I WILL
CONSIDER THE WELFARE OF
HUMANITY AND RELIEF OF
SUFFERING MY PRIMARY CONCERNS.
I WILL APPLY MY KNOWLEDGE
EXPERIENCE AND SKILLS TO THE
BEST OF MY ABILITY TO ASSURE
OPTIMAL OUTCOMES FOR MY
PATIENTS I WILL RESPECT AND
PROTECT ALL PERSONAL AND HEALTH
INFORMATION ENTRUSTED TO ME. I
WILL ACCEPT THE LIFELONG
OBLIGATION TO IMPROVE MY
PROFESSIONAL KNOWLEDGE AND
COMPETENCE I WILL HOLD MYSELF
AND MY COLLEAGUES TO THE
HIGHEST PRINCIPLES OUR
PROFESSION'S MORAL ETHICAL AND
LEGAL CONDUCT. I WILL EMBRACE
AN ADVOCATE CHANGES THAT
IMPROVE PATIENT CARE I WILL
UTILIZE MY KNOWLEDGE SKILLS
EXPERIENCES AND VALUES TO
PREPARE THE NEXT GENERATION OF
PHARMACISTS I TAKE THESE US
VOLUNTARILY. WITH THE FULL
REALIZATION OF THEIR
SPONSORSHIP SPONSOR ABILITY
WITH WHICH I AM ENTRUSTED BY
THE PUBLIC. BY PROHIBITING THE
APPLICATIONS C. QUOTAS AND
OTHER PERFORMANCE METRICS AND
RELATE TO QUALITY OF CARE. SB
THREE SIXTY WILL ALLOW
PHARMACISTS TO MORE FULLY AND
DELIBERATE HONOR THAT OATH. TO
MEDICAL DECISIONS BASED ON
PATIENT NEEDS UNBURDENED BY THE
DURESS CREATED BY CORPORATE
SALES QUOTAS. OR OTHER
PERFORMANCE MEASURES UNRELATED
TO QUALITY OF CARE THE
PROVISIONS CONTAINED IN THE
BILL REPRESENTS A MEANINGFUL
STEP TOWARD ENSURING. THAT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF PATIENTS
WILL ONCE AGAIN BE THE TOP
PRIORITY FOCUS. FOR
CALIFORNIA'S LICENSED
PHARMACIST. I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW THAT BEFORE WE GET INTO
QUESTIONS THAT I AM COMMITTED
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO FIND COMMON
GROUND. ON SEVERAL ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THESE ISSUES WERE NOT
BROUGHT TO US AND LET UNTIL
LAST WEEK. WE'VE ALREADY
SUGGESTED SEVERAL PROSPECTIVE
AMENDMENTS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ADVISED MUTUALLY AGREEABLE
LANGUAGE. AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. I HAVE ALREADY OFFERED
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD MOVE AWAY
FROM THE ORIGINAL PROVISION
MANDATING PHARMACY CLOSURES FOR
THE FIRST VIOLATIONS. CLOSURES
WOULD INSTEAD BE REPLACED WITH
MONITORED SUPERVISION I AM
PLEASED TO CONTINUING TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
CHAIR. THIS COMMITTEE AND
OPPOSITION ON THIS ISSUE.
ADDITIONALLY I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT ONE ISSUE IN THE
ANALYSIS WHICH WOULD LEAD TO
MISUNDERSTANDING HERE. THE
ANALYSIS PROVIDED TO YOU STATES
THAT A VIOLATION WOULD RESULT
IN A ONE MILLION DOLLAR FINE.
IN ACTUALITY THE BILL LANGUAGE
STATES THAT THE PENALTY MAY NOT
EXCEED ONE MILLION DOLLARS AND
IN MANY CASES DEPENDING ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF A VIOLATION.
THE PENALTY IMPOSED COULD BE
FAR LESS AS YOU ARE PROBABLY
AWARE THERE IS AMPLE PRECEDENT
IN CODE FOR THIS TYPE OF A
DETERRENT. WITH ME VIRTUALLY TO
TESTIFY THIS MORNING'S DR
JENNIFER COURTNEY A TRUSTEE AT
LARGE OF THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION. IN
ADDITION I ALSO TESTED RULE
WITH U. S. C. W. WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL AND MICHELLE RIVAS WITH
THE PROFESSIONAL PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION ON THE LINE. TO
ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. DEPRIVE VOTE THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU CENTER YOUR
WITNESSES MAY PROCEED.
ACCORDING HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
LOUD AND CLEAR PROCEED. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK AT THE COURT OF THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
MY NAME IS DR JENNIFER COURTNEY
AND I'M AN ASSISTANT PROFESSOR
AT CALIFORNIA NORTH STATE
UNIVERSITY COLLEGE OF PHARMACY.
AND I WERE CLINICALLY AS AN
INDEPENDENT PHARMACISTS. I WORK
IN THE COMMUNITY PHARMACY CHAIN
SPENDING FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
SO I CAN SPEAK TO THE ISSUE FOR
MY COLLEAGUES WHO CAN. WHO CAN
NOT FOR FEAR OF THE OUT OF
GRAHAM. I'D HELP PROVIDERS WE
ARE. TO FOR THE QUALITY CARE
OUR- THAT WHY WE CHOSE THE PART
PHARMACY PROFESSIONS. THERE IS
GROWING CONCERN AMONG FARM THE
WHO WORK IN THE FARMING CHAIN.
REGARDING QUOTE THAT
ESTABLISHED BY THE CORPORATE
OFFICE. THAT ARE BEING IMPOSED
ON FARMERS TO THE WITHOUT A
PARENT OR FOR THE CLINICAL
RESPONSE. REFER THE PHARMACY
HAVE TO THEIR PATIENTS. WE'VE
BEEN ARE CAN HELP. EXAMPLES
INCLUDE AND ROLLING PERCENT
PATIENTS AND I REFILL FOR OR
CORPORATE REWARD FOR. THE ONLY
A CERTAIN NUMBER OF RISK FOR OR
PER DAY WHAT YOU CAN TO TURN
OUR RECEIVE FOR THEIR- DOWN.
HELLO IT TAKES SOMETHING OUT
THE PHONE. HI PRESCRIPTION
VERIFIED THAT OF. AT THANKS FOR
A- AND COUNCIL THEIR PIECE.
BERMAN HE FELT FOR THE WHICH
CAN BE A DUE TO REIMBURSEMENT
RATES FOR. IBM. PLEASE ALSO
INCLUDE SHOT AND OTHER. QUOTE.
MANY THERAPY MAN AND MY REVIEWS
THAT WE GIVE OUR PEACE. AND
OTHER CLINICAL SERVE. AS BUT
THAT- SENATOR NEWMAN- SAID- WAS
ADMITTED FOR UNDERSTATE
PROTOCOL WITHOUT EIGHT
PRESCRIPTION FOR LIKE HOMEOWNER
THAT TRAVEL HEALTH AND LOOKING
AT THE. RIDERS IN THE PHARMACY
MARKET THE REDDITOR
COMPETITIONS AND INSURANCE THE
HEALTH OF THEIR PATIENTS ON THE
MEDICATIONS AND RECOMMEND OVER
THE COUNTER MEDICATION AMONG
OTHER DUTIES IN THE PHARMACY.
CORPORATE INTERFERENCE INTO THE
PRACTICE OF MOST HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONS THAT PROHIBITED.
SAME SHOULD APPLY DEPARTMENT B.
AS WELL. PHARMACISTS ARE HIGHLY
EDUCATED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS. WE ARE IN OUR
DOCTORATE DEGREES AND PHARMACY
AND WE ARE DOCTORS OF PHARMACY.
ARMISTICE ALSO COMPLETE A
MINIMUM OF FIFTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS OF CLINICAL TRAINING AND
ADDITION TO THEIR DIDACTIC
COURSES. THE ROLE OF
PHARMACISTS HAVE CHANGED
DRASTICALLY OVER THE YEARS WE
DON'T SIMPLY COUNT AND DEFENSE
MEDICATION. RATHER RATHER WE
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE PATIENT
CARE AND ARE OFTEN THE MOST
ACCESSIBLE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS FOR MOST OF OUR
PATIENTS. WE ARE THE MEDICATION
EXPERTS. WE SHOULD NOT BE
SUBJECTED TO ARBITRARY
CORPORATE METRICS WHICH ARE
INCONSISTENT WITH HOW OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS PERFORM
THEIR DUTIES FOR THEIR PATIENTS.
THESE METRICS OFTEN INTERFERE
WITH OUR ABILITY TO PROCESS AND
USE THEIR CLINICAL JUDGMENT AND
INTERFERE WITH PATIENT CARE.
CALIFORNIA MUST BE ON THE
PRACTICES OF IMPOSING ARBITRARY
BUSINESS METRICS ON PAR WITH
THIS. THE PERPETRATOR AHEAD OF
PROFIT OVER PATIENT CARE AND
SAFETY. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU DOCTOR BY UNDERSTANDING
THAT MS CRUEL IN HIS RIVAS OR
SIMPLY ON THE LINE FOR
QUESTIONS. THAT'S CORRECT MR
OKAY LET'S PROCEED TO HEAR FROM
ANY WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THERE ARE
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS EMILY HUGHES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY LET'S
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THREE
SIX TWO SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL WE WILL BEGIN. I
THANK THE CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. WE
WILL NOW GO TO LINE FORTY. FIVE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JENNIFER MALLEABILITY
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
THANK YOU CARE- INTERNET OR NEW
MAN WE SUPPORT THIS BILL- WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT ARE FOR
MUSICIANS SHOULD HAVE-
ARBITRARY QUOTAS PLACED ON THEM
PARTICULARLY DURING THAT TIME-
WHEN THEY ARE NEEDED TO FACT
NEEDING- THANKS AGAIN COBIT
EIGHTEEN SO THANK YOU WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. ONE FORTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING TURNED PAT WHALEN L. TO
FIFTY UNDER OF THE NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA YOU
DEVELOP CARE PROFESSIONALS
YUNEEC RT TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE CENTER
NAME IS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. SURE NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS LET'S NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IS
JENNIFER SNYDER ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
CHAIN DRUG STORES AND
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. IF YOU ARE WITH US
MISS SNYDER PLEASE BEGIN. YES
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK WELL THEN CLEAR
PLEASE PROCEED. GREAT THANK
YOU. YES THIS IS JENNIFER
SNYDER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS LISTED
CHEN AND THE NATIONAL CITY CAN
TAKE OUR DOORS. AND
UNFORTUNATELY TODAY WE ARE AS
OPPOSED TO SB THREE SIX TWO. I
WOULD FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS ARE
WORKING WITH US ON SOME OF OUR
REQUESTED AMENDMENTS. AND WHILE
WE ARE APPRECIATIVE OF THE
WILLINGNESS TO POPULAR CONCERN.
WHAT SHOULD BE BELIEVED AS
CURRENTLY. WILL DO MORE DAMAGE
THANK YOU SERVICE WITHIN THAT-
IN OUR CONCERNED WITH THE BILL
CENTER AROUND THREE HE. HURT
THE BILL WILL HAVE A
DETRIMENTAL IN ON A FARM YOU
CAN PUT YOUR BILL AT THE-
UTILIZED IN THAT KEEP TRACK OF
WHAT THE CORPSMAN THERE ARE.
ALL THE BOYS INCLUDING PHARMACY
PERFORMANCE NEXT TO EVALUATE
THE CAR. OF THEIR- AND ALSO
SUPPORTS WAR AT THE PLACE TO
CALL WORK. UNFORTUNATELY THE
CURRENT DEFINITION A QUOTE. IN
THE U. S. SO FAR. IT WOULD
PROHIBIT MOST PLAYED A CORPSMAN
VENTURE. UTILIZE BY A
PHARMACEUTICAL. THIS WOULD
INCLUDE ANY PATIENT HARM. BY
RADIO. AND PAYERS AS WELL. IT.
THE CARD CAN NOW IN AND TO TRY
PATIENTS EVERY A- PRIMING AND-
SENATE STATION ARE NOT. LONG
WAIT TIME. CUSTOMER SERVICE ARE
NOT DECLARE FOR THE- ALSO GET
PLAYERS AND REGULAR. ON CON
OVER TO THE WOULD. THE BILL
IMPOSES A- BUT WHAT WE BELIEVE
COULD BE- A MINIMUM ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. ON FARM THAT BY LATE
THE LAW. FINE NOTICE AND
PRIVATE AND WE DON'T KNOW THE
REAL FIND. THIS AMOUNT OF THAT
BASED ON. IN ADDITION THE
VIOLET COULD IMPART STORK ON A
LARGE SCALE WHICH WILL HAVE A
DIRECT IN ON P. ACCESS TO THEM
AND LYFT. HE POLICY THAT THE-
SICKENED AS A ALTERNATE TO THIS
LET'S JUST. WHICH IS TO REVIVE
STATE FARM DEPARTMENT
TECHNICIAN REYES. HELLO HAS
BEEN THE WITH THE WE SHOW THE
NATION WITH A ONE PART OF
TECHNICIAN TWO ONE DEPARTMENT.
THE TECHNICIAN PROVIDED CRUCIAL
CASH TO FORM AT THE TIME TO
MORE CANCER TEACHING CARE EVEN
ONE. PHARMACY TECH TO ASSIST.
WOULD MAKE IT DIFFERENCE THEIR
BILL RIGHT SERVICES PATIENTS.
AREN'T PERMITTED TO. THAT IF
THERE WERE ABLE COMPLETE SHASTA
MORE FORM. TECHNICIAN FOR THEIR
BACKING CALL. THE NUMBER OF.
FOR CO. AT THE TO PATIENTS WITH
A LIKE PER. WHY WE ARE IN
AGREEMENT WITH THE THAT IN
QUOTAS THE AND PEOPLE CARE
CLINICS PATIENTS TAKE AT RISK
IN A PRO. WE DISAGREE THAT ALL
MY SHOULD BE PROHIBITED
CERTAINLY DOES THE OF SHE BE
FINE BILLION DOLLARS AND
CLOSURE OF HUNDRED OF FARMERS
PROVIDE OF BILL. WE HAVE A
THIRTY MINUTE YA. THAT WILL
NEAR FOR QUALITY TO BILLS THAT
YOU. YET LET. AND IT PERSON OR
WE FINE PERFORMANCE VIOLATION
SISTER CALIFORNIA FARM. THESE
AND ALSO CLEAR. FOR PERFORMANCE
MEASURES. AT CAPPELAERE THE OF
WORK ON THE FARM. THE PHARMACY.
WE DO HAVE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE THIRD PARTIES ON
CONCERN THAT MY MONEY BECAUSE
TODAY. TWENTY MINUTES LATER.
CHECK WITH HERE AND GALLERY AND
UP AS TO THE BILL IF THERE ARE
ANY AND I SEE NO. WHAT'S MY TO
WHITBY IN ROOM ONE WHICH TO AND
UP TO THE BILL B. C. SIX TWO I
ALSO. SEE NO WITNESSES THERE
LET'S NOW MOVE TO WITH WAY TO
TEST THE TELL. SERVICE MR BY IF
YOU WOULD PROBLEM THOSE. IF
ANY. WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL.
THREE SIX TWO. THANK YOU TAKE
CARE IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE IN
EUROPE PRESS ONE ZERO TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OKAY COMMITTEE
CHAIR NO IN THE SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU-
LIST MODERATOR. LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS HERE
IN THE CHAMBER- FIRST- CENTER
LEYVA FOLLOWING BY FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR NEWMAN FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I ABSOLUTELY
LOVE THIS BILL AND IT'S
PROBABLY BECAUSE I ABSOLUTELY
HATE QUOTAS. I WILL BRING
EVERYONE BACK TO A COUPLE YEARS-AGO WHEN WELLS FARGO IMPOSED
QUOTAS AND THEY ULTIMATELY
ENDED UP PAYING THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN PENALTIES BECAUSE
THEIR EMPLOYEES FELT SO
COMPELLED TO MEET THOSE QUOTAS
THEY WERE ILLEGALLY AND
FRAUDULENTLY SIGNING PEOPLE UP
FOR ACCOUNTS THAT THEY DID NOT
ASK FOR. THE QUOTAS RARELY DO
WHAT THOSE WHO IMPOSE THEM
THINK THAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO
AS SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTED
PHARMACISTS FOR TWENTY YEARS
THESE ARE SOME OF THE MOST
CARING AND KNOWLEDGEABLE AND
CONCERNED PEOPLE I HAVE EVER
MET. AND WORKED WITH QUOTAS ARE
IMPOSED ON A PHARMACIST. YOU'RE
NOT JUST SIGNING UP AN ACCOUNT
THAT SOMEONE DIDN'T ASK FOR ONE
PHARMACISTS ARE PUSHED TO THE
TO THE EDGE. BOTH LIVES COULD
pBE IN DANGER SO I THINK ALSO
THAT THE PENALTY PART- YOU KNOW
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE PENALTIES
CORPORATIONS DELAY PENALTIES
BUT WITHOUT A PENALTY IS JUST A
SUGGESTION. SO YOU HAVE TO PUT
A PENALTY IN PLACE IF YOU
REALLY WANT THE POLICY TO BE
CARRIED OUT. THEN WHEN THE
OPPOSITION TALKED ABOUT THE
PERFORMANCE METRICS THAT THEY
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO BE PUT IN
PLACE I JUST THINK THAT THERE
ARE SO MANY WAYS THAT YOU THAT
A COMPANY HAS AN ABILITY. TO
SEE IF A PHARMACIST IS
PERFORMING OR PHARMACY IS
PERFORMING LIKE OTHER RELATIVE
TO THEIR PEERS. MAYBE L. A.
COUNTY LEVELS- PHARMACY WERE
ONLY FILLING HUNDREDS
PRESCRIPTION TODAY BUT MAYBE AT
SENATOR NEWMAN'S PHARMACY. THEY
ARE FILLING TWO HUNDRED TODAY
WELL WHAT IS SENATOR NEWMAN
DURING THAT CENTER LIVE IS NOT
DOING SO THERE ARE OTHER WAYS
THAN PERFORMANCE QUOTAS WHICH I
WILL SAY ARE USUALLY PUT IN
PLACE BY PEOPLE WHO. ARE
ACTUALLY DOING THE JOB TO GET
THAT KNOWLEDGE I HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE IN THE WORLD THAT
SENATOR NEWMAN WILL WORK WITH
ALL CONCERNED PARTIES. AND GET
TO A POINT WHERE EVERYBODY'S A
LITTLE HAPPY AND A LITTLE
UNHAPPY BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
THE COMMUNITIES WILL BE
PROTECTED I LOOK FORWARD TO
VOTING I ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU CENTER LEYVA CENTER PAN. I
THANK YOU THIS CHAIR- FIRST OF
ALL I EIGHT- SENTIMENT OF.
CERTAINLY PRETTY FISHY THAT-
ONES REPORTER ASPECTS OF THIS
BILL IS THAT WE NEED TO RESPECT
THAT PHARMACISTS ARE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS AND NEED TO BE
ABLE TO EXERCISE THEIR- OWN
JUDGEMENT. TO BE ABLE TO PUT
OUR PATIENTS FIRST AND I THINK
THAT'S THE HEART OF THE BILL.
YOU HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THE
DEFINITION OF QUOTAS AND- A
CERTAINLY. I SHARE MANY OF-
CENTER LEADERS CONCERNED ABOUT
QUOTAS THAT THEN ACTUALLY
INTERFERE WITH OR- THE JUDGE
THE PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT
PHARMACIST OR PUT REQUIREMENTS
ALL THEM THAT CAUSED THEM. THAT
WOULD PUT PRESSURE ON THEM TO-
EITHER CUT CORNERS OR- NOT BE
ABLE TO. EXERCISE. BASICALLY
ACT OF EARLY- IN FOR THE
PATIENT BUT GUESS IN TERMS A
QUOTE THE- THE DEFINITION
QUOTAS SO WE DO HAVE SOME CALL
IT WE DO HAVE. VARIOUS QUALITY
METRICS ARE DEFINED BY NATIONAL
QUALITY ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
NATIONAL QUALITY FORUM AND SO
FORTH- IS ARE. IN AND SO WILL
THOSE AND NOT BE I MEAN WITH
THOSE BE POTENTIALLY CONSIDERED
QUOTAS OR CAN YOU JUST MAYBE
TOUCH ON OR PERHAPS SPONSORS
MIGHT MIGHT TOUCH ON WE DO HAVE
SOME QUALITY MEASURES THAT ARE
OUT THERE. THAT ARE PUT FORTH
BY ACTUALLY NATIONAL QUALITY
ORGANIZATIONS OR BY LET'S SAY
THE PERFECT THE PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION SELF SO THE
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS
PHARMACISTS WOULD THOSE BE-
EXCEPT WITH. AN SO. BASICALLY
WITH THIS. I I'M SURE IT DOES
WILL BE IN. QUOTAS BECAUSE
REQUIRE MEASURES. I GUY TO
THINK A PERK. DR PRINCE SO- TO
BE CLEAR IT THE- COMMITTEE
FINDINGS USE THE PHRASE
PERFORMANCE METRICS AND
PERFORMANCE SCORES- NO IN THE
BILL THE CARD. DID WILL YOU
FIND THE PHRASE PERFORMANCE
QUOTA. BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE
NEED FOR- UNAMBIGUOUS AND NON
AMBIGUITY IF THAT'S THE RIGHT
PHRASE. THAT IT'S BETTER TO
WORK WITH. THE COMMITTEE WILL
WORK WITH. THE OPPOSITE MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS NO
AMBIGUITY. THAT WHAT WE'RE
DURING TO DO HERE- AND I
HOPEFULLY MADE IT CLEAR IN MY
OPENS- USED TO REMOVE THOSE.
QUOTAS RIGHT SPECIFICALLY. THAT
RELATE TO CORPORATE PRACTICES
OF CORPORATE INSTANCE SALES-
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE INTERFERE
WITH A LICENSED PHARMACIST BUT
BUILT TO DO THEIR JOB WITH A
CLEAR MIND- BUT THAT DOES NOT
MEAN THAT WE WOULD PREVENT. THE
THEIR EMPLOYER FROM OF VALUE IN
THE PERFORMANCE AND SOME SOUND
BASIS. IT'S A GREAT GUY YOU
KNOW GLAD TO WORK WITH. ALL
PARTIES TO MAKE SURE THAT IS
CLEAR IN THE FINAL VERSION THIS
BILL OKAY NO I APPRECIATE THAT
AND CERTAINLY- I WILL BE VOTING
FOR THE BILL TO KEEP IT MOVING
FORWARD I HOPE YOU'LL BE
LOOKING AT PERHAPS. ON A CALL
EXCEPTION JUST TO BE CLEAR TO
CLARIFICATION THAT A AND A
NATIONAL QUALITY MEASURE
DEATHS- I SUPPORTED BY THE
PROFESSION ITSELF OF PHARMACY.
ARE BOARDED- BY THE
INTERNATIONAL QUALITY MEASURES-
DEBT COLLECTION DATA FOR THOSE
WOULD NOT BE CONSIDERED- THE-
THE PROBLEM IN THIS INDIGENOUS
PROTECTED PARTICULAR BILL THANK
YOU KNOW GREAT AND JUST TO ADD.
PREFIGURE POINTS SO YOU KNOW
THOUGH THAT DATA METRICS ARE
INTENDED TO PROVIDE KIND OF A
YOU KNOW A BETTER GLOBAL VIEW
OF HAVING SHE WORKS HOW CAN
pTRYING TO DO IS. GLAD TO ALLOW
THAT- BUT DON'T WANT THE
EMPLOYER TO PLACE YOU KNOW
OTHER BURDENS ON THE PART. OF
PHARMACY SAID ACTUALLY
INTERFERE WITH THAT. HE THANK
YOU A CENTER PAN CENTER. A YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU I THINK
THERE'S A LOT THIS BILL TO- IS
REALLY REAL GOOD THAT REALLY-
PATIENT SAFETY. AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S- YOU KNOW. I'M VERY
PLEASED ABOUT THAT IF YOU GO
DOWN ON THIS QUOTA ISSUE AND
REALLY TO SENATOR PAINTS POINT
I. YOU'RE JUST READING THROUGH
THE ANALYSIS AND EVERYTHING I
WOULD THINK QUALITY MEASURES.
THAT YOU HAVE GOALS FOR WOULD
BE PART OF A QUOTA AND THAT
VERY MUCH CONCERNS B. I WROTE
THE BILL ON THE WELLS FARGO
QUOTA THEY DID PUT A BIG ANEL
IS THE END FOR WELLS FARGO I
DON'T THINK THEY WERE EVEN A
MILLION BUCKS BUT- BE THAT AS
IT MAY- BUT I THINK THAT THE-
PROGRAMS OFFERED TO PATIENTS.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ON WE
SHOULD NOT ALLOW OUR
PHARMACISTS TO BE HAVE QUOTAS
ON ANY OF THAT TYPE OF. REVENUE
OBTAINED SAME THING. I THINK
THAT THAT REALLY OBSCURES
PATIENT- QUALITY. AND- SHOULD
NOT BE ALLOWED. BUT IF THE
METRICS OF SOME KIND FOR
PRESCRIPTIONS BUILDING
SERVICES. RENDERED TO PATIENTS.
CAN BE IMPORTANT BECAUSE- I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF YOU EVER
FELT. THAT IN IN A BIT IN LINE
AT A YOU KNOW AT A PHARMACY AND
WAIT WAIT WAIT WAIT WAIT. YOU
KNOW WHAT I DON'T WANT TO DO
HERE IS- HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THE BILL
BECAUSE OF THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL AND ALL THE SIDE NOW- WE
HAVE OUR CONSTITUENTS. WAITING
LONGER LINES THAN THEY EVER HAD
HAD BEFORE I THINK THE FINANCE
FRANKLY I FIND THEM OUTRAGEOUS-
WE TALK ALL THE TIME ABOUT THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
OFTENTIMES WE VOTE ON BILLS
WE'RE JUST NOT THERE. I DO HEAR
THE- I'D I DID NOT HEAR ABOUT.
THE BILL'S AUTHOR REALLY
COMMENT ON THIS BUT I'D LIKE TO
SEE HIM- MOVE FORWARD IN IN IN
IN INTO THIS IN A MANNER. LOOK
AT WHETHER YOU'RE A
CORPORATION. I KNOW THAT WE ALL
TEND TO BRING CORPORATIONS IS
BIG BAD. THINGS IN OUR SOCIETY
WELL THE REALITY IS I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT'S TRUE I THINK
THERE ARE SOME THAT. YOU KNOW
CLEARLY ARE IN THEIR BEHAVIOR
SETS FORTH- THAT REPUTATION BUT
NEVER THE LESS I THINK WE NEED
TO HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S
REALLY- YOU KNOW. SOMETHING
BETTER. AND THEN I WONDER WHAT.
IT WHAT IS THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY DO HERE I MEAN WHY
DON'T THEY HAVE POLICIES- WHY
DON'T THEY SET THE STANDARDS ON
THESE TYPE OF THINGS AND WHY
ARE WE DOING THAT IN THIS
WORLD. I'M SORRY TO KEEP GOING
ON MISTER CHAIRMAN BUT IN THE
ANALYSIS- YEAH WE TALK ABOUT
HERS- ONE OF THE SPEAKERS SAY
PARTICULARLY THIS BILLS
IMPORTANT WITH PHARMACISTS WILL
BE CALLED UPON TO VACCINATE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHEN
THEY ALREADY HAVE OVERWHELMING
WORKLOAD. WELL WE'RE PUTTING A
BILL IN THE STATUTE THAT'S
GOING TO STAND WAY OUT PAST THE
COVE IN NINETEEN SITUATION
THAT'S A CONCERN TO ME- IT THEN
WE HAVE UNSOURCED REP. AND
SOURCE REFERENCE WANTED US
PERMISSION TO READ. FACEBOOK
ONE INVESTIGATION DOCUMENTS-
PHARMACISTS FEAR OF LOSING HIS
JOB IF HE DOES NOT COMPLY WITH
QUOTAS. NO DATE NO SOURCES THEN
THE SECOND SOURCES IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN DOT DOT DOT DOT
DOT A. B. SO I AM AT ELEVEN.
CLEARLY SOME WERE ALSO IN THE-
ANALYSIS THERE'S A TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE REFERENCE. SO ALREADY
THAT'S TEN YEARS OLD BUT THEN
IN FAIRNESS TO- THE PRO SIDE
HERE THE NEW YORK TIMES ARTICLE
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY YOUR
ISSUE SO I'M NOT SAYING THAT
THIS BILL WAS NOT NECESSARY IN
FACT I THINK THERE'S A LOT IN
THIS BILL THAT WE SHOULD BE
MOVING IT- BUT I'D LIKE TO SEE
THE AUTHOR I I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY. EVEN
AFTER ALL THE ARGUMENTS I'VE
MADE AGAINST THIS BILL BECAUSE
I BELIEVE THAT SENATOR- WILL-
YOUR WORK ON THIS. IT WORK ON
THESE ISSUES. TO DO IT BUT I
RESERVE THE RIGHT- ON THE FLOOR
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL. IF I DON'T
THINK IT'S GONE FAR ENOUGH
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU US SENATE- CENTER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI RIGHT
THIS IS A VERY INTERESTING BILL
CENTER VERY INTERESTING BILL
THAT I THINK IT'S GIVE US ALL A
LAW ALL A LOT OF TIMES TO STOP
AND- THINK. AND THINK ABOUT OUR
OWN EXPERIENCES AND- THROUGH.
THROUGH MY EXPERIENCE I'VE
SERVED ON BMP NOW IT IS MY
SECOND HOUSE I'VE HAD SOME
HISTORY. ON THIS COMMITTEE. AND
WHEN YOU TALKED ABOUT NOW WE'RE
ASKING PHARMACISTS TO DO
EVERYTHING. ALL THESE NEW
THINGS. THAT MEAN OPTOMETRIST
PHARMACIST EVERYBODY HAS ASKED
US IF THEY CAN DO MORE THINGS
RIGHT IT'S NOT IT'S NOT AS
REQUIRING PEOPLE TO DO MORE. IT
IS THE PROFESSIONS COMING TO US
AND SAYING. IN THE SCOPE OF OUR
PRACTICE IN THE SCOPE OF OUR
LICENSE WE ARE WE CAN'T DO MORE
WE CAN DO MORE. AND SO IT'S
OKAY TO MORE NOW. L. MAN SO WE
HAVE GOING ON. AND THEN AT THE
SAME TIME WE HAVE THE
CONSOLIDATION OF BUSINESSES SO
MORE MORE THE SMALL PHARMACIES
MINE THE SMALL PHARMACY WE USE
FOR EVER FORTY NINE OR DRUGS.
WHICH WAS THERE IN STOCK IN
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS NOW GOING
OUT OF BUSINESS. TO TRY TO FIND
A SMALLER ONE IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF THE
PROLIFERATION OF THESE LARGER
ONES. JIM IT'S AN EASIER OR
MORE. BUYING IN BULK IS AN
EASIER WAY TO DO BUSINESS JUST
TO SAY- SO I THINK WE'RE GONNA
SEE MORE MORE THIS SO AS WE
BEGIN TO SEE MORE CARE.
PHARMACY OPTOMETRIST. ALLERGIST
DERMATOLOGIST. IN IN THESE MORE
CORPORATE TYPE SETTINGS. ARE WE
GOING TO PUT OURSELVES IN A
POSITION. THAT WE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A CORPORATE BROWN ON
MEDICINE YOU CAN'T HIGHER
POSITIONS BECAUSE THE SAME
THING BUT HE'S A PHARMACIST WHO
ARE EMPLOYEES. OF A CORPORATION
BEING ASKED DIEM SO I AGREE
WITH CENTER DOT I DON'T I DON'T
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
QUOTAS. FOR THE SAME TIME IF
SOMEBODY IS AN EMPLOYEE YOU
NEED TO HAVE SOME KIND OF
METRICS TO EVALUATE THEIR
PERFORMANCE BY- AND I THOUGHT
THE- THE OPPOSITION THE ISSUE
ABOUT MEDICAL OR- PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS WAS ALSO GOOD
POINT. THEY DO BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE MORE CAPACITY TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE MORE SUPPORT OF- THAT
TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THE PROCESS
MOVING A LOT MORE SUPPORT
PROFESSIONS ALLIED PROFESSIONS.
SO ANYWAY I AM ALSO GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY BUT I
DO THINK IT RAISES A LOT OF
INTERESTING ISSUES- ABOUT WHERE
WE END UP IF WE KEEP EXTENDING.
THE ABILITY FOR PEOPLE TO
PRACTICE AND DIFFERENT KINDS OF
SETTINGS. THEN IT HOW DOES THAT
FIT INTO THE SETTINGS THAT ARE
BEING CREATED. THROUGH WITH OUR
SAME PROCESS. OF EVOLUTION SO-
NOT REALLY A QUESTION I GUESS
BUT A LOT OF. A LOT OF
PONDERING. I APPRECIATE THAT SO
THANK YOU- CENTER EGGMAN CENTER
BATES. THANK YOU I JUST LIKE TO
CONCUR WITH MY COLLEAGUES ON ON
SOME OF THE VERY GOOD AND NOBLE
POINTS IN THE FIELD THAT TIME
TO ISSUES THAT ARE REALLY
TROUBLING. FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY AS THAT OF.
THE PENALTY FOR ONE IN A CHAIN
WOULD EXPAND TO ALL IN A CHAIN
AND THAT COULD CLOSE ON
HUNDREDS OF PHARMACIES ACROSS
THE STATE AND THAT WOULD PUT
THEM OUT OF BUSINESS AND REALLY
POTENTIALLY HARM. ARE PROBABLY
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS USING THOSE
PHARMACIES THAT SAY IT'S AN
RIDE DATA WALL GRAINS WHEREVER
THAT HAPPENS TO BE SO I THINK
WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT. THE
PENALTIES SPECIFICALLY AND HOW
THAT WOULD AFFECT A WHOLE CHAIN
NUMBER TWO IS THE DEFINITION OF
A COMMUNITY PHARMACY. ARE WE
HAVE ONE IN OUR MIND MY
COMMUNITY THAT'S REALLY AREN'T
INDEPENDENTLY OWNED AND
OPERATED BY A PHARMACIST YET HE
COULD BE OR THEY COULD BE
DEFINED AS A COMMUNITY PHARMACY
MAKE ONE MISTAKE AND- I BELIEVE
THAT PARTICULAR COUNTY WILL PUT
THEM BASICALLY OUT OF BUSINESS
AND THEY ARE A COMPOUNDING.
PHARMACY LIKE OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE SENATOR- JEFF STONE
HOW'D YOU KNOW AND- DO A LOT OF
VERY SIGNIFICANT WORK AND
COMING UP WITH THOSE COMPOUNDS
THAT ARE VERY VERY IMPORTANT TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE A SPECIAL
NEEDS SO I THINK THOSE TWO
AREAS NEED A LOT MORE WORK.
THAT TIME CERTAINLY ON THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM YOU CALL YOU FROM
ORANGE COUNTY I THINK. IF OF
PUTTING SOMETHING OUT THERE
THAT CERTAINLY NEEDS A CLOSER
LOOK CALM ON THE QUALITY ISSUE
THAT TIME I WILL BE SUPPORTING
IT TODAY AND HOPE THAT WE'LL
GET CLOSER TO WHAT IS A
BALANCE. OF FOUR OUR CHAIN
PHARMACIES THAT ARE INDEPENDENT
PHARMACIES AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
OUR OUR CONSTITUENTS ON IF THE
VERY VITAL SERVICE SAW
CERTAINLY FOR ALL OF US. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER BATES
CINNAMON. THANK YOU MR CARE- I
APPRECIATE COME OF US. THEY AND-
YES I THINK INTERESTING IS IT
TO DESCRIBE THE BECAUSE IT DOES
RAISE ALLOW OF ISSUES. YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE COIN
OF THE BILL OF TRYING TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS. TRYING TO
ELIMINATE BAD BUSINESS
PRACTICES. AT THE SAME TIME YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THESE
COMPANIES LIKE CVS AND
WALGREENS- THEY'RE TRYING TO.
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING
GOOD CUSTOMER SERVICE THAT
THEY'RE KEEPING GOOD
PHARMACISTS AND- SO IS TOUGH IN
SOME WAYS BECAUSE THEY'RE THERE
THEY ARE VERY LARGE
ORGANIZATION THEY'RE TRYING TO.
HEAR THE PRACTICES OF CORPORATE
GOVERNANCE I GUESS MY QUESTION
AND THEN I HAD A COMMENT AFTER
THAT- IS CENTER NEWMAN IS- YOU
KNOW YOUR BILL WOULD. AS I
UNDERSTAND PROACTIVE CERTAIN.
THINGS FROM USED AS A FIX. OR
NUMBER. TO PRESS FILLED
SERVICES RAND. PROGRAMS OFF
AROUND TEN AND I GUESS MY IS
THIS PROVIDE THE U. OF THOSE.
AS FACT AND I THOUGHT YOU I
KNOW SENATE FINANCE OF COURSE.
BUT I WAS CLEAR IN THE ANSWER-
OR IT'S JUST- THE IS LIKE
STRAIGHT LINE. NOW LIKE LAKE
EFFECT COMPANY LIKE C. V. SAID-
WE THINK PRESCRIPTIONS FILLED.
ANY SEVEN BACK I THINK OF THIS
FOR AN EDGE. PER WHERE RACE
WAS- ELIMINATED YOU CANNOT USE
RACE AS A QUOTE OF IT BUT IT
CAN BE USED AS A FACTORIN THE
SUPREME COURT'S. DECISION BAKI.
IT AND I GUESS THE QUESTION I
HAVE IS COULD THESE THINGS TO
BE USED AS FACTORS IF AN
EMPLOYEE. A PHARMACIST WAS YOU
KNOW JUST CONSISTENTLY BEHIND
ON NUMBER PRESCRIPTIONS FILLED
SERVICES RENDERED- COULD THAT.
B. USES A FACTOR IN IN HOW THE
COMPANY PROCEED. SURELY THERE
IS A GOOD QUESTION SO- I THINK
THERE IS ANY QUESTION SO IS
FACTORS SO THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S NOTHING STOPPING. A AN
EMPLOYER FROM USING. THOSE
METRICS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS FOR
ASSESSING PERFORMANCE WHAT WERE
ENDEAVOR TO DO IS TO PREVENT
THE ASSIGNMENT OF QUOTAS FROM
INFLUENCING THE WORK IN
INTERFERING WITH THE JUDGMENT
OF A PROFESSIONAL PHARMACIST SO
EASIER TO TRACK DATA-
REASONABLE I THINK TO MEASURE
SOMEBODY. PERFORMANCE IN THE
AGGREGATE OVER YOUR- BUT WHAT
WE DON'T WANT. IS FOR- MEASURES
OR INCENTIVES THAT HAVE
BOTHERED TO DO WITH PATIENT
CARE YEP- FROM BEING CENTRAL TO
THAT PHARMACISTS WORK HOPE OF
INTEGRATION YEAH NO AND I SAID
REALLY SUPPORT THAT GOAL AND I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS A YOU
KNOW AND I THINK CENTER EGGMAN
REALLY ELOQUENTLY DESCRIBED
THIS. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT YOU
KNOW THE LAW IT'S OFTEN AN
INARTICULATE A BLUNT
INSTRUMENT. AND- YOU KNOW THIS
DOES RAISE QUESTIONS SO. AM
GLAD THAT YOU'RE OPEN TO
AMENDMENTS- YOU KNOW I WILL
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY AND
JUST INTEREST INTERESTED TO SEE
HOW PROCEEDS BUT- I THINK. YOU
KNOW I WILL CONCUR WITH MY
COLLEAGUES- ABOUT SOME OF JUST
THE OVER ARCHING CONCERNS TO
GET REYES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENTIMENTALITY ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS. LET ME- FOR MINE YOU
KNOW AND THINKING ABOUT THIS
QUOTA ISSUE AND AS YOU KNOW I
CAME OUT OF THE NATIONAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD WERE.
PRODUCTION QUOTAS WITHIN A
UNIONIZED SETTING WE'RE
CERTAINLY ISSUES OF MANDATORY
SUBJECT TO MANDATORY.
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND I
WROTE RECOGNIZE HERE WE HAVE
BOTH- UNIONIZED FACILITIES AND
NON UNIONIZED FACILITIES SO.
THAT'S REALLY AN ISSUE FOR
ANOTHER DAY. BUT I WAS STRUCK
BY THE FACT THE AS I THOUGHT
ABOUT IT THAT REALLY A PHARMACY
IS NOT A WAREHOUSE- AND THEY
HAVE DIFFERENT MISSIONS. A
DIFFERENT- EMPLOYEES DOING
DIFFERENT THINGS. I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PERFORMANCE
EVALUATION ISSUE AND SO IS THIS
BILL I'M SURE MOVES FORWARD.
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE IDEAS THAT YOU
TAKE A- MORE- DETAILED LOOK AT
THE AT THE ISSUE OF PERFORMANCE
EVALUATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
CLARIFIES THAT EMPLOYERS.
CERTAINLY HAVE THE ABILITY AND
THE RIGHT TO EVALUATE
APPROPRIATELY- BY THE
PERFORMANCE OF EMPLOYEES IN
THEIR EMPLOY. AND PERHAPS AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO
INDICATED. SPEND MORE TIME-
DEFINING THE USE OF BENCHMARKS.
WHICH TYPICALLY ARE UTILIZED IN
THE MEDICAL FIELD FOR A WHOLE
VARIETY OF- OF REASONS AND
ISSUES INCLUDING. THE QUALITY
CONTROL WHICH IN ESSENCE IS THE
VERY ESSENCE OF PERFORMANCE SO.
WITH THAT I WILL BE- SUPPORTING
THE BILL. BUT DO WE HAVE A
CENTER NEWMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SO. I DISS. I THINK THE
FIRST TIME I'VE HEARD OF BILLS
CRIME ALL THE TIME JUST
INTERESTING- REMINDS ME OF A
SEINFELD EPISODE ABOUT THE
INTERESTING LOOKING BABIES.
CLICK HERE TO DISCOVER BABY IS
INTERESTING YOU. THINK SOMEBODY
ELSE- LET LET ME RESPOND AND
CLOSE VERY QUICK BECAUSE I
SOME OF THE VERY GOOD QUESTIONS
ASKED- WITH RESPECT TO THE
PENALTY QUESTION. TO BE CLEAR.
YOU KNOW THE PENALTY WOULD ONLY
APPLY IT IN AN INSTANCE WHERE
THE VIOLATION WAS DIRECTLY
ATTRIBUTABLE TO CORPORATE
POLICY- SO IN THE CASE WERE A
BRANCH. OR AN EMPLOYEE TO
BRANCH WERE FOR- THE YOU KNOW
SAY THE MANAGER. WERE WERE
APPLYING. QUOTAS UNLESS THAT
WAS A CORPORATE POLICY THE
POLICY WILL NOT APPLY MOREOVER-
YOU KNOW WE MAY PROVISIONS- TO
ENSURE A SORT OF A YOU KNOW THE
TO REASONABLE STEP. STEPPING UP
OF PENALTIES TO INCLUDE A
WARNING. SECONDLY YOU KNOW I
THINKIT IS. RELEVANT TO THIS
NOTION COMMUNITY PHARMACIES
THAT THAT IS FOR WHATEVER
REASON KIND OF A TERM OF ART-
IN THE EXISTING LEGISLATION
THAT IS THE TERM THAT USE
REFERRED ALL PHARMACIES SO THAT
MIGHT BE. WORTHY OF TIGHTENING
UP- BUT- YOU KNOW I DO. THAT
AND APPRECIATE THE INPUT OF ALL
MY COLLEAGUES HERE- WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE. THAT WE DON'T
UNINTENTIONALLY CREATE MORE
PROBLEMS THAN WE SOLVE I THINK
THAT'S TRUE ALL LEGISLATION-
BUT GENERALLY I THINK PUT IT
WELL. YOU CAN'T FIND MANY GOOD
EXAMPLES WHERE CORPORATE
QUOTAS. LEAD TO UNAMBIGUOUSLY
GOOD RESULTS- IF ANYTHING- THEY
TEND TO CREATE SYSTEMIC
INCENTIVES FOR MISBEHAVIOR- AND
IN THIS CASE I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. TO CONSIDER
THE VALUE OF NOT LETTING THAT
HAPPEN- PHARMACISTS ARE IN FACT
THE LAST- BARRIER IN SOME CASES
TO REALLY DANGEROUS
CONSEQUENCES. IN THE USE OF
DRUGS AND IN FACT WE'VE ASKED
PHARMACISTS IN THE IN THE HEAT
OF THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC. TO DO
SOME REALLY EXPLICIT THINGS
THEY REQUIRE REQUIRED BY LAW.
TO TRACK A SERIES OF RED FLAGS
ANYTHING THAT GETS IN THE WAY
OF THAT OR OTHER- DELIBERATE
CARE OF THEIR PATIENTS- IT
SHOULD BE AVOIDED- AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATE-ROOM THREE OF
A MOTION ON SENATE BILL. THREE
SIX TWO VESTED INTERESTING BILL.
BUT CENTER PAN THE MOST IS TO.
THE SENATE OVER. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEMS OF CENTER
BILL THREE SIX. NEWMAN DO YOU
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
TO PLEASE HAVE YOUR MICROPHONE
ON. ROTH ROTH AYE MELENDEZ.
SORRY NO MELENDEZ INDO
ARCHULETA ARE VIRTUAL LEAD AT
HIGH BEATS NO BE NO BACKER. HI
BAKER HI DODD DODD AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE HER TADO. JONES NO
JONES NARROW LEYVA HI LEAVE AT
I MEAN MILLION HI YOU MANAGE
NEWMAN AYE AYE CHAU ABODE. PAN
HI CAN I. ALEX CURRENT VOTE IS
NINE TO THREE WILL HOLD THE
MATTER OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
I SEE CENTER BORJAS IN THE
CHAMBER LET'S MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE SENATE BILL FOUR
THREE ZERO SIR BORDERS. GOOD
MORNING. GERMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT TODAY SAID A BILL FOR
THIRTY A BILL THAT WILL HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES BY CREATING A
PROCESS BY WHICH STATE AGENCIES
CAN ESTABLISH PROCEDURES FOR
THE REDUCTION OF CIVIL
PENALTIES UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES. THIS BILL PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF THE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TWO WEEKS AGO AND
CLOSELY RESEMBLES SB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN WHICH LAST YEAR
PASSED OUT OF THE SENATE
UNANIMOUSLY. BUT UNFORTUNATELY
WAS STALLED BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. MANY SMALL BUSINESSES
DO NOT HAVE THE SAME
ORGANIZATIONAL RESOURCES
AVAILABLE AS LARGER COMPANIES
SUCH AS HAVING LEGAL
DEPARTMENTS AND COMPLIANCE
DEPARTMENTS. THIS CAN
IMPARTIALLY RESULT IN A VERY
REAL OPPORTUNITY IMBALANCE
BETWEEN MEDIUM AND LARGE
CORPORATIONS AND SMALL MOM AND
POPS TRYING TO SURVIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. MODELED AFTER THE
SMALL BUSINESS REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT ACT PASSED BY
CONGRESS IN THE NINETIES SB
FOUR THREE ZERO DOES NOT.
REPEAT DOES NOT LESSEN
REGULATORY STANDARDS FOR REDUCE
THE RULE MAKING AUTHORITY OF
THE STATE AGENCIES. INSTEAD IT
SEEKS TO PREVENT PENALTIES FOR
MINOR INFRACTIONS FROM LEADING
TO FINANCIAL RUIN. UNDER THIS
BILL SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
REQUIRED TO MEET CERTAIN
CRITERIA TO QUALIFY FOR PENALTY
REDUCTION. INCLUDING THAT THE
VIOLATION DID NOT INVOLVE
WILLFUL OR CRIMINAL CONDUCT IT
DID NOT POSE A SERIOUS HEALTH
SAFETY OR ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT.
SB FOUR THIRTY ALSO PROVIDES
FACTORS FOR STATE AGENCIES
SHOULD TO DETERMINE IF. IF AND
TO WHAT EXTENT THE PENALTIES
SHOULD BE REDUCED IF AT ALL
WHICH INCLUDE. THE DEGREE TO
WHICH SMALL BUSINESSES
COOPERATED DURING ANY
INVESTIGATION. ENGAGE IN
SUBSEQUENT ACTION TO CORRECT
THE VIOLATION. PRIOR HISTORY OF
MEETING REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS
IF THE PENALTY WOULD IMPEDE THE
SMALL BUSINESSES FROM
CONTINUING TO OPERATE IN IF THE
ACTIONS WERE NEGLIGENT. STATE
AGENCIES WOULD ALSO BE
AUTHORIZED TO APPLY CONDITIONS
TO THE REDUCTION OF PENALTIES
INCLUDING REQUIRING THE SMALL
BUSINESSES TAKE CORRECTIVE
ACTION OR TEN SPECIFIED
TRAINING. COLLEAGUES THOUSANDS
OF SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
SHUTTERED THEIR DOORS DURING
THE PANDEMIC IN MANY MORE WILL
FOLLOW. NOW MORE THAN EVER
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO TAKE
INSTITUTIONAL ACTION TO PROVIDE
REGULATORY FINANCIAL RELIEF TO
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE A
VITAL PART OF OUR COMMUNITY.
PRIORITIZING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITY WHILE
ALSO SUPPORTING MEASURES TO
RESPONSIBLY AND SUSTAINABLY
STRENGTHEN OUR ECONOMY IS A
RESPONSIBILITY WE HAVE AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY. COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB FOUR THIRTY. CENTERS
MY UNDERSTANDING YOU HAVE SOME
LEAD WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
WOULD YOU IDENTIFY THEM PLEASE.
BEAR WITH ME. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
WE SHOULD HAVE DAVID BUTLER AND
WE SHOULD HAVE LAWRENCE GAIDEN
IF I PRONOUNCE THAT CORRECTLY.
YEAH THIS IS DAVE BUTLER PLEASE
PROCEED AND A- THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING I'M MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I AM
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB FOUR
THIRTY ON BEHALF OF YOU CAN THE
UNITED CHAMBER ADVOCACY
NETWORK. WHICH IS A COALITION
OF SEVEN LOCAL CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE ACROSS FOUR COUNTIES
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING OVER FIVE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUAL BUSINESSES. EACH
YEAR WE SURVEYED CHAMBER
MEMBERS AND CONSISTENTLY AMONG
THEIR TOP CONCERNS IS THE
BURDENSOME COSTS OF COMPLYING
WITH AN EVER INCREASING NUMBER
AND COMPLEXITY OF STATE
REGULATIONS AS SENATOR BORDERS
NOTED SMALL BUSINESSES DON'T
HAVE THE STAFF OR RESOURCES AS
THE LARGER BUSINESSES AND
CORPORATIONS TO NAVIGATE THE
STATE'S BUREAUCRACY. WITH SB
FOUR THIRTY THE LEGISLATURE HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE
THE CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF
SMALL BUSINESSES TO OUR STATE'S
ECONOMY AND SERVE AS A PARTNER
IN THEIR SUCCESS SB FOUR THIRTY
LEVERAGES THE GOOD WORK OF
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES ENABLE
THEM TO ASSIST SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND OPERATORS AND
AVOIDING. NON COMPLIANCE AND IN
SOME INSTANCES PROVIDE A
REDUCTION OR WAIVER OF COSTLY
FEES WHILE THE SAME TIME
INCLUDING PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE
SOME BAD ACTORS DON'T BENEFIT
FROM THESE CHANGES I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SB FOUR THIRTY AT THE MUCH
NEEDED RELIEF TO CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER BUTLER DO WE
HAVE MISTER GOODEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS. AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ONLINE.
YES YES MORE GERMAN THE LOWER
GAIN POPULAR CPA SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR THIRTY AT
THE BILL THAT WILL PERTAIN TO
BUILD SMALL MANUFACTURING JOBS
IN THE STATE. A MINUTE AGO MORE
CRITICAL IN THE WAKE OF THE
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
MANUFACTURING FIRM 90% OF WHICH
ARE SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED.
MOMMY BACK TO GENERATE HIGH
LEVEL OUTPUT. ROBBERIES
REGIONAL ECONOMIES. THAT'S A
CRUCIAL MEMBER OF OUR MAIN
FACTIONS OF SUPPLY CHAIN IN A
MILLION THEY CALL ME BACK IS
REALLY STEPPED UP AS LEADERS
INCOME PARTNERS STATE. INDIA
KOBE NINETEEN RECOVERY RESPONSE
SEPARAE SO PURPOSING OPERATION
CITIES DEGREES COULD BE AND-
ADOPTION OKAY. HE KEEP PLEASE
TAKE CRIMES GOING- COMMITTEE
THE CHALLENGES MALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE SMALL FACTORS BAY.
ADMITTEDLY THE LACK OF
PERSONNEL AND HR AND- TO
CONTINUE KEEP UP. WITH THE
DYNAMIC- REFORM AT THE STATE-
THIS BILL ENCOURAGE FIFTEEN
YEAR CORRECTED. OF THOSE AND
UNINTENTIONAL. I DO NOT HAVE
KNOW THE YOU RATHER THAN
LOOKING THOSE THINGS TO GO TO
FOR- DOES NOT A COVER BACK ARE
GIVEN OPPORTUNITY FOR SMALL ME
BACK. SKATER INSTEAD OF. BY
NEGATIVE TO. TRUE THOUGH THE
MONEY WAS TAKEN GET UP MEANS
THE- WALL BUT FROM THE BY THE
STATURE HI COST OF LEGAL AND
SETTLEMENTS. REGIONS IN THE
ABOUT DOLLARS. WE TO THE
BUILDING BUT IF YOU SMALL ME
FACTORS IN CALIFORNIA. AND UP
FOR THE REGIONS WERE ASK I
BOUGHT AS BEFORE THIRTY THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR TEST NOW
IT'S MOVE TO THE- TO ANY
WITNESS AND SOME. OF THIS BILL
SENATE FOUR THIRTY I SEE NO
WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
I SEE NO WITNESSES THERE LET'S
MOVE TO THE WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE TALK OF
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MISTER
MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
WAITING TO TESTIFY WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU CHAIR. PLEASE
JOHN IF YOU WISH TO CALM AT
TIME. PLEASE PRESS ONE THE-
PRESS ONE TO EUROPE. WE HAVE
PLEASED PERSON WHO'S SIX THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT. WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE.
FOURTEEN THANK YOU MISTER
NUMBERS MATTER THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
PLEASE. SURE NO ONE ELSE THE
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
WELL HAVING HEARD FROM THE
SUPPORTERS ITSELF ALL THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION I SEE
NONE WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN OPPOSITION OF SENATE
BILL FOUR THREE ZERO. I SEE NO
BUT THIS IS LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELEPHONE CONFERENCE
SERVICE IN OPPOSITION MR
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THOSE WITNESSES PLEASE.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL FORWARD OBVIOUSLY
SYMPATHETIC TO ALL OF THE
STRUGGLES EMPLOYERS ARE GOING
THROUGH DURING THE PANDEMIC WE
THINK THAT- THIS BILL REALLY
DOES CREATE A DIRECT RISK TO
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
WORKERS AND REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THAT. AS WRITTEN THIS BILL
WOULD DIRECT STATE AGENCIES TO
EITHER TOTALLY ELIMINATE OR
REDUCE PENALTIES FOR SOMEWHERE
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF 97% OF
ALL BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT MEETING CERTAIN CRITERIA
AND JUST TO TAKE THE EXAMPLE OF
WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY
REGULATIONS WE HAVE A VERY
FEDERAL BODY OF LAW THAT
DEFINES THINGS LIKE SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS TO FIND THINGS LIKE.
WILLFUL VIOLATIONS THIS WOULD
APPEAR TO POTENTIALLY THROW ALL
OF THOSE OUT AND START OVER IN
A PROCESS THAT. DOESN'T INVOLVE
WORKERS IN ANYWAY TO HAVE THE
WHAT THE DOCTOR OF THESE WOULD
BE AN THE EFFECT WOULD IS THAT
COMPANIES WOULD EITHER GO AWAY
ENTIRELY OR BE REDUCE SICKNESS.
AND IN TURN REDUCE INCENTIVE TO
COMPLY WITH THOSE LAWS THAT
HAVE DONE A JOB SO FAR WHERE
THEY CAN APPLY IN KEEPING
WORKERS PURGING OF TO PROTECT
WORK FROM EXPOSURE TO THE BY
AND WE THIS BILL. IF APPROVED
DOES WOULD DEFINITELY WERE THAT
AND ENDANGER HEALTH WE- DROPPED.
NEXT FELIZ. YES WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL PERSON WHO TO THIS
TO THE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE. SIXTY FIVE. JACKIE CHAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER TRADE
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO AS-
IF YOU. COULD THANK YOU.
MODERATOR WOULD YOU JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT MISTER CHECK
OKAY WE HAVE WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON TO SIGNAL
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE. WE'RE GOING TO
GO. TO ONE SIXTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CARS ONE OF THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
STE MODERATOR WOULD YOU CHECK
THE LEARN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK MISTER
CHAIR WELL LET'S GO AHEAD AND
CHECK THE LINE ONE MORE TIME TO
MAKE SURE WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE BEFORE WE MOVED TO MY
COLLEAGUES. PLEASE DO. THE
FINAL OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO YOU
STILL WISH TO COMMENT. I KNOW
WHEN THE SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
ANOTHER WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
LET'S MOVE THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO MY COLLEAGUES ON THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU-
CHAIR AND- THE NEXT ONE THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AS A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND SOME
OF THE MAJOR FRUSTRATIONS- FOR
SMALL BUSINESS THAT DOESN'T.
NECESSARY HAVE A LEGAL
DEPARTMENT OUR HR DEPARTMENT OR
SO FORTH BUT- I DID HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS- ACCORDING THIS BILL-
SO FIRST OF ALL- I MEAN THERE'S
CERTAIN I WOULD SAY THERE'S NEW
REGULATIONS AND WHICH PERHAPS
AGAIN BEING A SMALL BUSINESS
WOULD NOT NECESSARILY HAVE THE
KIND OF TEAM A LARGER BUSINESS
WOULD HAVE TO TRY TO ANALYZE. A
NEW REGULATION ARE MAY NOT BE
AS ENGAGES A LARGER BUSINESS
MIGHT AND DEVELOPMENT OF A NEW
REGULATION BUT THEN THERE ARE
OTHER REGULATIONS THAT ARE LONG
STANDING THAT. HOPEFULLY- THERE
SHOULD BE MORE FAMILIARITY WITH
THE BY ALL BUSINESSES AND WE
CAN CERTAINLY HAVE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE ROLE OF STATE
AGENCIES AND HELPING. TO TACKLE
SMALL BUSINESSES UNDERSTAND HOW
TO COMPLY WITH THOSE
REGULATIONS WHETHER WE'RE DOING
ENOUGH THERE- BUT CAN YOU SPEAK
TO. THE IS THIS BILL
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN JOSE NEWER
REGULATIONS THAN WHICH- SMALL
BUSINESSES TRYING TO COMPLY MAY
NOT OF NESTLE FIGURED IT OUT.
VERSES AND LONG STANDING
REGULATION IN WHICH THE SMALL
BUSINESS CERTAINLY SHOULD.
HOPEFULLY BEEN- FAIRLY AWARE OF
AND COMPLIANCE SO- AND WHERE TO
COMPLIANCE AT LEAST COMPLAINTS
THAT REGULATION SHOULD BE MUCH
CLEARER AS TO HOW TO COMPLY SO
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THIS DOES THIS
BILL DISTINGUISH BETWEEN. THOSE
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES ARE IS
THIS TREATING ALL REGULATIONS
THE SAME. RESEARCHER PLEASE
RESPOND YES I WANT TO THANK THE
A CENTER VERMONT SACRAMENTO-
THAT'S A FANTASTIC QUESTION I'M
REALLY GLAD THAT- THAT HE
POSTED. I WANT MAKES IT
SOMETHING VERY MAKE SOMETHING
VERY CLEAR WITH THIS PROPOSED
PIECE OF LEGISLATION IS THAT IT
IS NOT MANDATING. THAT FINDS BE
REDUCED FAT ALL. WHAT IS DOING
IT IS- IT IS AUTHORIZING OF THE
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS AND
REGULATORY ENTITIES- UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF THE STATE TO DEVISE
THEIR OWN POLICIES THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR INDIVIDUALS- TO BE
LOOKED UPON. UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR FINANCIAL
REDUCTION. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
IT DOES NOT TAKE AWAY THE
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY OF ANY
DIVISION OF THE STATE. IT IS
ONLY ALLOWING FOR A- A VEHICLE
FOR DISCRETION TO BE EXERCISED
SO TO YOUR POINT THIS AND
THAT'S A PERFECT EXAMPLE YOU
GET ITUATIONS WE HAVE EXISTING
BUSINESSES TRYING TO DEAL WITH
CUMBERSOME NEW REGULATIONS AND
KEEP UP. OR YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
EXISTING BUSINESSES- WITH THE
BOULDER REGULATIONS AND VICE
VERSA SO THIS COULD BE A NUMBER
OF WAYS THIS PLAYS ITSELF OUT.
I THINK GO TO YOUR POINT WHEN
YOU HAVE A NEW BUSINESS AND
THERE'S A TIRE BODY OF LAW AND
REGULATION. IT IT'S CHALLENGES.
WE HAVE AN EXISTING BUSINESS
THAT IS EXPECTED TO ABIDE BY
LONG STANDING LAWS. THEN THAT
IS EXACTLY WHAT THE DISCRETION
IN THE LEVELS OF ENQUIRIES BY
THESE RELEVANT DEPARTMENTS
SHOULD BE ABOUT. SHOULD YOU
HAVE KNOWN. WERE YOU IN
DECORATIONS IN NOT DOING X. Y.
OR Z. IF YOU WERE THE PENALTY
STANDS- THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF
THIS PIECE LEGISLATION IT
SIMPLY AUTHORIZES THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO CREATE POLICIES.
WITH THE PERSON'S MOST
KNOWLEDGEABLE I CAN'T COMMENT
ON A VISALIA RESTAURANT
FACILITY FOR A SMALL BUSINESS
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT WOULD COVER
ALL CONTACTS THE PERSON'S MOST
KNOWLEDGEABLE WILL BE ABLE TO
WEIGH IN AT THAT MOMENT IN BE
ABLE TO EXPLAIN. THIS WAS
NEGLIGENCE OR THIS WAS WILLFUL
OR THIS WAS ACCIDENTAL BUT
SERIOUS IN WHICH CASE NO
REDUCTION I WAS GONNA BE ON THE
TABLE. AND ALSO JUST TO CLARIFY
FOR EXAMPLE AND CHECKED EVEN
HERE ON THE FLOOR TODAY WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT POTENTIAL
OBVIOUSLY CAN POTENTIAL LAWS
BECAUSE THEY THEY HAVE PASSED
YOUR YARD. FOR GENERALLY WE- WE
MAY SET A PENALTY AT A RANGE.
OR SAY A MAXIMUM OF. SO GIVEN
THE FACT THAT WE'RE THE
LEGISLATURE USUALLY PASS A BILL
AND PUT ON THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
WE WANTED TO BE AN SOURCE. IS
THAT ARE WE GIVING AGENCIES
DISCRETION TO. ACT IN A WAY
THAT MAY NOT BE CONSISTENT WITH
A SET OF PENALTIES THAT WE
PASSED YEARS OF LEGISLATURE SO
I MEAN SIZE WILL GIVE A RANGE
SO I GET THAT OKAY FINE FOR
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE
LOWER END TO RANGE VERSUS THE
HIGHER IN THE RANGE. BUT ARE WE
ALL SET SO IS THIS BILL SAYING
THAT. THEY COULD. SO I COULDN'T.
GO BE. THAT IS- YES SKILLED
LOWERED THE RATE OF MORTALITY
THAT WE ESTABLISHED HERE W.
PASSED IN A PREVIOUS- PIECE OF
LEGISLATION HERE I. INSIDE
SCOPE. FIGURE OUT THE SCOPE OF
THIS BILL CERTAINLY IF THE-
DISCUSSION WE'RE GIVING THE
AGENCY. CERTAINLY THANK YOU
AGAIN THE INTERCONNECTEDNESS
BETWEEN. OTHER BODIES OF LAW
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN.
THAT ARE BEING FILLED IN A BY
THE BY. VERSES THIS IS THAT. IT
IS ABSOLUTELY IF IT IS A
PRIORITY BASED ON LEGISLATION
OR A REGULATORY EXPECTATIONS
THAT THERE BE A CERTAIN SET OF
CONTACTS. ALL FOLLOW THROUGH
ON. THAT WILL ABSOLUTELY BE
REFLECTED. IN WHAT IS EXPECTED
OF THOSE WITHIN THE RELEVANT IN
RESPECTIVE INDUSTRIES. IT IS
NOT INTENDED AT ALL. TWO CUT-
ARM OF BY THIS SCANDAL BILLIONS
OF THESE- REGULATIONS. IT IS
ASKING HIS ASKING THE
GOVERNMENT. TO BE MORE HUMAN.
IN UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT'S LIKE
UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES
I'LL. GIVE YOU ONE IN
PARTICULAR. D. SALINAS DOLLARS
A- I ALSO JUST KIND OF THE TIME
AT OTHER PLACES SINCE TWO BUT
JUST TO CLARIFY- SO THIS BILL
WOULD. BASICALLY YOU
ENCOURAGING AGENCY TAX SOME
DISCRETION BUT THAT THIS STILL
HAS TO BE THE FOR. OF EXISTING.
THAT WE FOR PASSED YEARS A
LEGISLATURE ANOTHER WORDS IF WE
SET A MINIMUM. THE AGENCY CAN'T
WAIT AND- OF THE PANEL THAT HAS
IT. AS STAFF CERTAINLY THE
ADMITTED THE L. AGENCY WE OFTEN
THEM SOME DISK. ENTER OF.
PENALTY AND INTERPRETATION AND
SO FORTH THAT'S WHY AND THEN
THAT GOES REGULATORY PROCESS
BUT THIS. BILL IS TALKING ABOUT
REGULATION IT WOULDN'T ACTUALLY
AFFECT THINGS ARE ACTUALLY IN
CODE GIVE THEM UP UNTIL THE IN
AGENCY OR AN ABILITY TO.
ESSENTIALLY LEAVE A PART OF THE
CODE THAT WE HAVE ACTUALLY.
THAT WE AS A LEGISLATURE
ACTUALLY PASSED. IF I GET A-
YES YOU. SO THERE WASN'T MUCH
OF A RESTAURANT IN VACAVILLE.
AND THIS- THIS- WASN'T. AND SHE
WAS FINED THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS-
ON BECAUSE THERE WAS NOT THE
PLASTIC- COVER ON THE
ELECTRICAL OUTLET HEADING DOWN
INTO THE BASEMENT IT WASN'T IN
THE RESTAURANT. BUT IT WAS DOWN
INTO INTO INTO THE BASEMENT AND
SHE SAYS IF ID KNOWN THAT IT
WOULD COST TWENTY FIVE CENTS.
IN A IN IN IN IN BEEN COMPLIANT
I WOULD HAVE DONE. BUT TO BE TO
FIND THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FOR
TWENTY FIVE CENT PROBLEM KIND
OF GOES AGAINST WHAT. THE
PURPOSE OF GOVERNMENT IS IT IS
TO PROMOTE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WELFARE IT IS ALSO TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AFTER THE OUR ECONOMY. AND IN
THAT IN THAT SPIRIT I BELIEVE
WE CAN BRING A HUMAN ELEMENT TO
THIS ISSUE WITHOUT MANDATING
ANY. DISREGARD FOR EXISTING LAW
TO YOUR POINT. AND THANK YOU
AND I JUST WANT OTHER ONE LAST
QUESTION FOR ME AT LEAST- V. IN
THE DEADLY SIN IN ALICE'S
INVENTIONS THAT- THIS NOTICE BY
STATE CIVIL PENALTY WAIVER
REDUCTION SHALL BE BY SMALL
BUSINESS POINT FOR KATRINA
VIOLATION DID NOT POSE A
SERIOUS HEALTH SAFETY
ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT- I THINK
BY DEFINITION. A REGULATION
RELATED THAT'S RELATED TO
HEALTH SAFETY ENVIRONMENT. IS
SUPPOSED TO BE- INTO TO REDUCE
THE RISK OR THE THREAT OF THAT
SO I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW THIS BILL- SO THIS BILL
ESSENTIALLY EXEMPTS HEALTH
SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATIONS FROM THE- FROM THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL OR I'M-
I'M JUST. FROM DEBT IS DOLLAR
DOESN'T APPLY TO THIS
PARTICULAR REGULATIONS I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY CERTAINLY
THAT'S SOMETHING THE OPPOSITION
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT. AND WE
DO HAVE YOU KNOW- WE DO HAVE.
HEALTH AND SAFETY ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATIONS FOR THE VERY REASON
OF TRYING TO PREVENT THREATS SO
INHERENTLY THOSE REGULATIONS-
SHOULD NOT BE THE ONES THAT
WERE. WAITING OR OR OR OR NOT
TANTALIZING FOR SO I JUST
WANTED TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE-
HOWTHIS PROVISION OF LEASES
DESCRIBED AND NOW IT SAYS.
INTERFACES WITH THE OVERALL
BILL. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN I
THINK I'M IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE DEFER TO THE PRACTICAL
ELEMENTS OF- THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL. AND THE REALITIES ON THE
GROUND. AND SO THE PERSON'S
MOST KNOWLEDGEABLE ARE THOSE
THAT REPRESENT THIS THE
DIVISIONS OF THE STATE IN A
SPECIFIC- IN A SPECIFIC WAY OR
SPECIFIC MANNER WITH A CERTAIN
JURISDICTION. IF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE SAYING THAT
CONDUCT ABSENCE OF CONDUCT IN
THIS INCIDENT DIDN'T POSE A
THREAT WELL THEN YOU'RE NOT
ELIGIBLE. IN THEIR
DETERMINATION IF IT WAS A
THREAT THEN IT'S SIMPLY NOT
GOING TO BE A VENUE OR NOT JUDY
TO PURSUE. BUT WE HAVE TO BE
RON REALISTIC HERE THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO IN SUPPORT THIS
IS IN NO WAY MEANS BY NO MEANS
ENCOURAGES WILLFUL. OR CRIMINAL
CONDUCT THAT'S OFF THE TABLE
AND IT DOES ALSO IS SERIOUS
HEALTH SAFETY OR ENVIRONMENTAL
THREATS BUT I GO BACK TO THE
ONE EXAMPLE I MENTIONED EARLIER
IN ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND. THAT
I'VE THAT I'VE HEARD OF IN IN
DURING THE PANDEMIC OF
INDIVIDUALS TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING WANT TO DO THE
RIGHT THING WILL TAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTION AFTER POINTED
OUT. BY TO ASSESS THE MAXIMUM
PENALTY WITHOUT A MECHANISM. BY
AT ANY LEVEL THAT ALLOWS THEM
FOR THOSE CONSIDERATIONS TO BE
PART OF THE PROCESS IS IT WILL
FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR AND I
BELIEVE THAT IF YOU REACH OUT
INTO THE COMMUNITIES THOSE
COMMUNITIES WANT TO DO THE
RIGHT THING BECAUSE THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL. THAT
MANDATES THE STATE MUST REDUCE
THE PENALTY ACTUALLY NOTHING
THAT'S WHERE I THINK THERE'S A
BIT OF HANG UP WITH SOME OF THE
FOLKS THAT HAVE CALLED IN. AND
I'M GLAD WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CORRECT THEIR UNDERSTANDING.
IS THAT THIS DOES NOT MANDATE A
REDUCTION AT ALL. AT ALL. AND
THERE'S ENOUGH SEEDS IN. FOR
THE PRAC. PRACTICAL DESIRE
OUTCOME TO BE ACHIEVED. THANK
THINKING FOR ADDRESSING QUITE
AT THE THIS PARTICULAR
IMPORTANT WE ARE NOT UNDERMINE
ITS EXISTING CODE AS WELL BUT-
THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN CENTER MEN.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE CHAIR-
CENTER BORDERS I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DIRECTIONALITY
OF THIS BILL IT'S EXACTLY THE
TYPE OF LEGISLATION WE NEED
MORE OF. THE INCIDENT YOU
DESCRIBED WITH THE RESTAURANT
IN YOUR DISTRICT- MATCHES THE
EXPERIENCES OF MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES AROUND THE STATE- I
DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS JUST
BECAUSE I MY MAIN CONCERN IS
MAKING SURE WE'RE NOT CREATING
A HUGE LOOPHOLE HERE- IN THE
NAME OF. WHAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING
IT CREATES HUGE PROBLEMS FOR.
BUSINESSES THAT WILLFULLY OR
INTENTIONALLY- OVERLOOKED THESE
REGULATIONS IN WAYS THAT ARE
CONTRARY TO PUBLIC POLICY AND
SO I GUESS MY FIRST QUESTION IS
REALLY TECHNICAL ONE FROM ONE
LAW PROFESSOR TO ANOTHER- YOUR-
LANGUAGE APPLIES TO VIOLATIONS.
IT SAYS THE WAIVER WILL APPLY
THE FOLLOWING CONDITIONS
VIOLATION THAT DID NOT INVOLVE
WILLFUL. IS A SERIOUS HEALTH
SAFETY OR ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT
INTEREST QUESTIONS I IS THAT
BOTH OR ORIGIN OR- VISIT IN
MANDARIN OR THERE BECAUSE I
WASN'T ON CLEARING THE STATURE.
THANK YOU FOR. THIS THIS REALLY
IS GETTING INTO OUR- OUR
ACADEMIC BACKGROUND I
APPRECIATE THAT IT'S KIND OF
LIKE THE OXFORD COMMA- MIGHT MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE WAY THAT
LEDGE COUNCIL- DRAFTED THIS. IS
THAT IT IS A SERIES OF ORDERS.
OKAY THAT'S THAT'S SO YOU'RE
SAYING THAT HE DOES NOT THEN
THE THING THAT I GUESS WE'LL
JUST POINT OUT YOU WOULD NOT
NEED TO SHOW. WILL FOR SOMEBODY
WOULD NOT NECESSARILY NEED WILL
FOR CRIMINAL CONDUCT.
ALTERNATIVELY IF THE VIOLATION
DID NOT POSE A SERIOUS HEALTH
SAFETY ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT
EVEN IF IT WAS WILLFUL. IF THIS
IS AN OR- THEY WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO RELIEF AND ONE WHICH ARE
ANDERSON YOUR QUESTION SO THE
WAY THAT IT'S CRAFTED RIGHT
NOW. WERE YOU REFERRING BONTA
HEALTH COMMON SAFETY COMMON FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT YES-
SUBSET SECTION. B. SLASH ONE
AND TWO. OR THAT IS- THE THOSE
ARE SERIES ABOARD DOES BECAUSE
THOSE COMMENTS ON THE ON THE
SECOND HALF OF THE WAY IT'S
WRITTEN IS YOUR ELECTION ON THE
FIRST ARC CONDITION PRECEDENT
YES I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
JUST WITHOUT GETTING INTO
CONDITION PRECEDENTS OR THINGS
LIKE THAT- YOU'RE SAYING THIS
POLICY OF RELIEF THAT IS TO SAY
BUSINESS THAT VIOLATES A LAW OR
REGULATION IS SUBJECT TO
REDUCTION IN PENALTIES IF THEY
MEET ONE OF THE FOLLOWING
CRITERIA HI OTHER. THE
VIOLATION DID NOT VIABLE FOR
CRIMINAL CONDUCT OR THE
VIOLATION DID NOT POSE A
SERIOUS HEALTH SAFETY
ENVIRONMENT IT'S ACTUALLY THE
AND THE INVERSE IS WHAT WOULD
ALLOW YOU TO BE ELIGIBLE TO BE.
CONSIDERED I'M NOT A RIGHT. I'M
I'M READING THE WAY OF THE I'M
SORRY SO THE FALL SHALL BE. TO
VIOLATE BY SMALL BUSINESS THAT
MEETS THE FOLLOWING CRITERIA.
SUBSECTIONONE THE VIOLATION
DID NOT INVOLVE WILL FOR
CRIMINAL CONDUCT. SUBSECTION TO
THE VIOLATION DID NOT POSE A
SERIOUS HEALTH SAFETY
ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT IT DOES
REDUCE QUALIFIERS FROM THE
ABILITY FOR THE RESPECTIVE
STATE. INSTRUMENT OR AGENCY. TO
BEGIN REVIEWING THAT AND IF
THEY IF THEY DETERMINE THAT
INDEED SO I'M I'M JUST READING
THE LANGUAGE RIGHT NOW BUT BUT
IF YOU PUT AN ORDER IN THERE
I'M JUST GONNA POINT OUT TO
YOU. THAT YOU ARE THAT'S
CONTRADICTORY TO WHAT YOU'RE
CLAIMING ABOUT THE BILL
BECAUSE- IF IT'S AN FOR IN
THERE IT WHAT THIS SAYS IS THAT
YOUR THE WAIVER POLICY APPLIES
TO ANY BUSINESS. THAT MEETS THE
FOLLOWING CRITERIA ONE THEY
THEY DIDN'T DO THIS ON PURPOSE
IT WASN'T WELL FOR CRIMINAL. TO
THE VIOLATION DIDN'T POSE A
SERIOUS HEALTH SAFETY OR
PROVIDE REMOTE THREAT. I WOULD
SUBMIT TO YOU IF IT'S A WAR.
YOU'RE GONNA GET RID OF THE
WILLFUL OR CRIMINAL AS LONG AS
IT DID NOT POSE A SERIOUS
HEALTH SAFETY OR ENVIRONMENTAL
THREAT.  THINK YOU NEED AN END
IN THERE TO MAKE IT THE WAY YOU
WANT. AND I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
AS A FRIENDLY AMENDMENT I'D
WANT TO ADD THAT AND BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN
IT'S JUST NOT CLEAR. YOU KNOW
WHAT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING- THAT THIS- THIS
ATTENTION TO DETAIL ON TO THIS
MATTER- I WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY.
PLEASE VETERANS TEN I JUST ONE
TO MAKE SURE THAT SALUTE AGAIN
AS YOU KNOW. IN I CAN DO IS- AS
THIS MOVES FORWARD SHOULD IT.
HAS THIS COMMITTEE TO. WORK
WITH YOU AND- CAL. TO MAKES
THAT THE- IN. OR AND ALL THE-
AND CAN BE LANGUAGE. IS
ABSOLUTELY- AND I'M NOT TRYING
TO PICK FOR THE DAY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE CAPTION YOU'RE NOT
SETTLING. I GUESS THE OTHER
QUESTION- YOU KNOW YOU YOU SAID
A FEW TIMES THAT- IF YOU'RE
NEGLIGENT. THEN YOU DON'T GET
ANY RELIEF. BUT THE WAY I
UNDERSTAND THE MECHANISMBY
WHICH YOU'RE DOING THIS THAT'S
NOT NECESSARILY RIGHT RIGHT
THAT- THE OPERATIVE LANGUAGES
THAT IS WILL FOR CRIMINAL
CONDUCT RIGHT SO. THAT TAKES IT
OFF THE TABLE IF IT'S WILL FOR
CRIMINAL CONDUCT THEN YOU DON'T
GET YOU'RE NOT SUBJECT TO
RELIEF BUT IF IT'S NOT WILL FOR
CRIMINAL. THEN YOU ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR RELIEF UNDER THE POLICIES
DEVELOP A DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES. AND ONE OF THE MANY
FACTORS THAT THEN GETS
CONSIDERED IS WHETHER NEGLIGENT
OR NOT. NOW MY CONCERN HEREIS
YOU KNOW IF YOU LOOK TO THE
OPPOSITION'S LANGUAGE THEIR
CONCERN IS ONE I THINK A LOT OF
A SHARE WHICH IS. THERE WILL BE
BUSINESSES THAT ACTION VERY
VERY BADLY AND IGNORE THI. AND
AS YOU KNOW WILLFUL OR IF IT
CRIMINALS VERY DIFFICULT TO
PROVE IN ANY COURT SAID. AND I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS WOULD YOU
BE OPEN TO OR OR MAYBE YOU
THOUGHT ABOUT THIS AND
DISMISSED IT NINETY INTEREST IN
YOUR REASONING- WHY NOT ADD
GROSSLY NEGLIGENT OR WHY NOT DO
SOMETHING LIKE NEGLIGENT AS A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW NEGLIGENCE IS A LOT
EASIER PROVE GROSS NEGLIGENCE
IS HARD TO PROVE BUT IT'S
EASIER PROVEN WILLFUL WHERE YOU
JUST HAVE TO SHOW SOMEONE.
ACTUALLY MEANT TO DO THIS AND
THAT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO DO
IN A COURT WITHOUT SOME KIND OF
A SMOKING GUN. AND THAT MAKES
THIS YOU KNOW ALMOST ALL
BUSINESSES I THINK WOULD UNDER
THIS LANGUAGE BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE POLICIES. AT WHICH POINT
NEGLIGENCE WOULD THEN BE A
FACTOR THAT COULD BE CONSIDERED
SO I GUESS THEY THOUGHT MY
QUESTION IS IF YOUR INTENTION
WAS TO SAY. THAT NEGLIGENCE IF
THE BUSINESS WAS JUST TOTALLY
IGNORING ITS REGULATORY
OBLIGATIONS THEY SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO DO THIS WHY NOT SORT
OF PHRASES IN STRUCTURED THAT
WAY AND ONCE AGAIN ON YOU BRING
UP SOME- SOME IMPORTANT POINTS-
YOUR LEGAL MIND IS GIVING YOU
INSIGHT. INTO PARTICULARLY THAT
I THINK IT'S HELPFUL THAT COULD
MAKE THIS BETTER. AND I CAN EAT
EASILY- REVISIT THIS AND WOULD
EVEN ASK FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE
AND IN DOING SO- TO FINE TUNE
THIS. IN THAT THE BEST WAY
POSSIBLE BECAUSE ONCE THE- THIS
WILL NOT BE IS NOT IS. TO AND
BY ITS BY THE- THAT- THAT WERE
MORE FORWARD WITH ANY WITH.
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS IN THE
COMING DAYS. IS NOT DESIGNED TO
ALLOW FOR WILLFUL IGNORANCE.
INTENTIONAL OVERSIGHTS. OR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT WANT TO
SKIRT THE LAW. THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE ARE ALLOWING THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE WANT. WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT BUSINESSES- ARE
GIVEN SOME EGREE OF- OF ALL
VENUE THAT. DIVISIONS OF THE
STATE HAVE A MECHANISM WITHIN
THEIR OWN RESPECTIVE
DEPARTMENTS TO EVALUATE THESE
INSTANCES AND I MIGHT ALSO SAY
THAT THE FACTORS OF THE STATE
AGENCIES- SHOULD USE. IS ALSO
IF AND TO WHAT EXTENT PENALTIES
ARE EVEN ELIGIBLE RATE
REDUCTIONS ARE ELIGIBLE IF.
SOME OF THEM ARE NINE TWO TO BE
ELIGIBLE AT ALL. THAT'S OKAY IF
THE VIOLATIONS OR THAT TYPE OF
DANGER BASED ON THE PERSON'S
MOST KNOWLEDGEABLE IN THAT
SPECIFIC INDUSTRY- WITHIN THIS
THAT THE STATE AGENCIES. THEN
THEY DON'T DESERVE THE
REDUCTION AT ALL IT'S NOT A
RIGHT IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY IF I
AND I APPRECIATE THAT A SENATOR
I THINK- YOU KNOW THIS SOUNDS
LIKE A VERY ACADEMIC TECHNICAL
CONVERSATION BUT- IT'S
OBVIOUSLY VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE DIFFERENCE. FOR
AVERAGE PEOPLE WORKERS SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. IS GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT- AND AGAIN I JUST
EMPHASIZE WILL FOR CRIMINAL IS
GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
PROVE FOR MOST WORKPLACE
VIOLATIONS- IF YOU'RE OPEN TO
AMENDING THAT IN WAYS THAT
WOULD TRY TO OUR NARROWLY
TAILOR THIS I WOULD BE- WILD
ABOUT SUPPORTING THIS AND
POTENTIALLY COOPERATING- AND
TODAY I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL.
AND GIVEN A DIMINISH YOU
SUGGEST IF YOU'RE OPEN TO AND-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS LONG AS
YOU DON'T CHARGE MEAN HOURLY
RATE PROFESSOR I WILL
ABSOLUTELY. WORK WITH YOU HIS
MUCH IS POSSIBLE. AT THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER. OKAY SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU- MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU TO THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM IRVINE
WORKING THROUGH THAT I HAD A
FEW COMMENTS AND I'M NOT A
LAWYER BUT I THINK THAT HE GOT
TO THE POINT OF THAT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT AND THAT NEEDS TO
HAVE A DEEPER DIVE BUT I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A CAUCUS OF
THAT HAS BEEN DEVELOPED IN OUR
LEGISLATURE SINCE WE HIT THE
PANDEMIC IN MANY BUMPS IN THE
ROAD FOR MANY OF OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES HIS CALL THE OF
SOLUTION CAUCUS. AND THIS TO ME
WOULD BE- BILL THAT SHOULD BE
ON THE TOP OF THEIR AGENDA
BECAUSE IT. SETS FORTH I THINK
OF THE PLANET WHERE WE CAN TAKE
A CLOSER LOOK AT OUR
BUREAUCRACIES. AND HAVE.
IN
THIS PANDEMIC THAT HAVE. FALLEN
UPON OUR SMALL BUSINESSES WHICH
ARE AS WE KNOW THE ECONOMIC
ENGINE OF THE NATION. SO I AM
PREPARED TO- MOVE THE BILL TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. AND- REALLY
COLD BONTA TO SENATORS GET
TOGETHER. REFINANCE AND MAYBE
THIS IS OUR FIRST OF STEP. OUT
TAKING A LOOK AT OUR
BUREAUCRACIES THAT SEEM TO HAVE
MORE- LET'S SAY A FORTY OVER
THE LEGISLATURE ITSELF AND I'VE
RAISED THIS ISSUE MANY TIMES SO
WHEN WE LOOK AT AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT BOARD. WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE COASTAL COMMISSION NOW
ALL OF THE BUREAUCRACIES ARE
ESTABLISHED SEEM TO REACH
BEYOND MAYBE WHAT THE INTENT OF
SOME OF OUR LEGISLATION IS
BEYOND. FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE ATTEMPTING TO DO OUR BEST
JOBS ARE VERY BEST JOB FOR THE
CONSTITUENCIES THAT WE SERVE.
SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
GREAT DISCUSSION. A HANDGUN
AGAIN I MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU SURVEYS- ANY OTHER COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES- CENTER PENA COMING
BACK TO THE WELLS OKAY SORRY I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY EGGMAN
HERE FROM THE AUTHOR ARE YOU
COMMITTING TO INCLUDING
NEGLIGENCE IN THE FUTURE
AMENDMENT TO THIS BILL I. IN
THAT DIALOGUE WITH CENTER MINOR
YOU'RE NOT SURE I HEARD THAT
EXCITE CONFIRM THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO INCLUDE NEGLIGENCE AS
A SO YEAH I'M I'M I'M FINE WITH
BUSINESSES THAT ACT IN GOOD
FAITH AND YOU KNOW MAYBE THEY
MISSED SOMETHING BUT SOMEONE
WHO'S JUST NEGLIGENT ISN'T EVEN
TRYING TO COMPLY WITH THE
REGULATION THAT'S A LITTLE
DIFFERENT TO ME SO CAN YOU JUST
PLEASE VERIFY THAT YOU'RE
COMMITTING TO COMMIT TO INCLUDE
NEGLIGENCE THIS. IS A ISSUE. IN
IN YOUR BILL IN THE FUTURE. I'M
AB- GONNA CHU WITH THE WITH WE
WITH THE CENTER AND LUNCH
COUNCIL I BELIEVE THAT'S
PROBABLY WHERE WE'RE GOING TO.
WE'RE PROBABLY GOING TO PUT IT
IN. BUT I WOULD I DON'T LIKE
TELLING WHAT YOU'RE A
COMMITMENT THAT YOU INTEND TO
PUT NEGLIGENCE AND- THAT THE I
HEAR YOU SAID TALKING ALLEGE
COUNCIL BUT YOU YOURSELF YOU'RE
YOU COMMITTING. I MEAN I'M NOT
A LAWYER SO IJUST WANT YOU
KNOW I HEALTH I'LL TAKE YOUR
WORD FOR IT. JUST TELL ME THAT
YOU PLAN TO INCLUDE NEGLIGENCE
IS ONE OF THE TRIGGERS. FOR
THIS BILL. I AM PLANNING ON
INCLUDING NEGLIGENCE ON AFTER
CONSULTATION WITH VILLAGE
COUNCIL AND- THE DIVIDING THE
WORD THAT YOU DON'T PUT THAT IN
THERE. LET'S LET'S NOT FORGET.
THE LANGUAGE THANK YOU. RIGHT
MUCH. SENATE THANK YOU MISTER
SO OPTION TENNESSEE PUT WELL
SHE UP I HAVE A SIMILAR ON MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T CREATE LED
THE JUSTICE NECK TO INTENSE ON
INTO- AND SO. BUT I WILL AGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR EDITOR RESPECT
WE TRYING TO DO THIS IS A VERY
CHALLENGING STATE. TO DO
BUSINESS. BUT IT'S ALSO TRUE
THAT- YOU KNOW IGNORANCE OF THE
LAW IS NOT AN EXCUSE- IN SO
MANY OF THESE REGULATIONS ARE
CARD OR DULY IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT BUSINESSES NOW TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW BUT EDUCATE
THEMSELVES AS TO THE LAW. AND
SO YOU KNOW I WOULD ECHO THE
CONCERNS CENTER COMMUNITY MOVE
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT- THAT
IS RENDERED CLIPS. THANK YOU OF.
BONO CENTER MEN I JUST HAD A
QUICK CLARIFYING- COMMENT AND
WITH ALL RESPECT TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN FULLERTON-
SOMETIMES IGNORANCE AS AN
EXCUSE FOR THE FOR BREAKING THE
LAW IT DEPENDS ON THE LEVELS OF
INTENT AND REQUIRED SO I WOULD
ONLY SAY THAT YOU KNOW IT NOT
NOT TO SOUND LIKE A LAWYER BUT
ONE OF THINGS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE IS WE'RE MAKING THE
LAW. IN SOMTIMES LIKE
IGNORANCE YOU KNOW WILLFUL
IGNORANCE I THINK NO ONE EXCUSE
BUT SOMETIMES IF IT'S A YOU
KNOW A GOOD FAITH IGNORANCE
THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE WE
MIGHT ONE EXCUSE THAT. I THINK
I'VE SEEN NO FURTHER MIKE
SIERRA- CENTER GORGEOUS YOU DID
NOT KNOW THAT WE HAD A
JUDICIARY TO THE NAME OF THE
COMMITTEE BUT HERE WE ARE. I
JUST HAVE A JUST A QUICK
COMMENT- YOU KNOW OSHA WORKERS
COMP OF READY OF OTHER AGENCIES
IN THE STATE ALREADY INCLUDE
PROVISIONS FOR REDUCTION IN
PENALTIES AND CITATIONS FOR
SMALL EMPLOYERS WITH MITIGATING
FACTORS IN HIS EYES I READ WHAT
I READ- ICE I THINK THAT IS
YOUR IDEA HERE TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT. FOR SMALL EMPLOYERS
MITIGATING FACTORS AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE AGENCY OR THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PROCEDURES OR
POLICIES IN PLACE TO ACCOUNT
FOR THOSE MITIGATING FACTORS
WHEN SETTING. FINES AND
PENALTIES IS THAT CORRECT
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT IN IT THOSE
IF THOSE DIVISIONS OF THE STATE
ALREADY HAVE FOR THOSE
PROVISIONS THAT ACCOUNT FOR
MITIGATING MEASURES- THEN. THAT
SATISFIES THE INTENT FOR THAT
PARTICULAR DIVISION OF THE
STATE CAN YOU MAY SO YOU I
DIDN'T RELOCATE THE BILL BUT
YOU MAY NEED TO TAKE ANOTHER
LOOK AT YOUR BILL ON THAT
PARTICULAR POINT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. BUT TO THE EXTENT IT'S
NOT THAT IT'S CRYSTAL CLEAR.
THIS OBVIOUSLY SOUNDS LIKE A
WORK IN PROGRESS SO LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING IT- AT SOME
LATER DATE I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL- TODAY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER PROGRESS
WITH RESPECT TO THE LANGUAGE
THANK YOU- CENTER BURGESS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING US FOR THE SPIRITED
DEBATE- THIS IS HOW LEGISLATION
IS MADE BETTER. AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'VE DONE-
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO MAKING
THIS A BETTER PRODUCT WITH YOUR
WITH YOUR SYSTEMS. COLLINS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU SIR GORGEOUS THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
BATES THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS PLEASE MAKE SURE TO
HAVE YOUR MICROPHONE ON FILE
ITEM THREE SB FOUR THIRTY
FORGES DO YOU PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROTH. ROTH HI
MELENDEZ AYE MELENDEZ AYE
ARCHULETA ON VIRGIL OUT I'D BE
FINE BATES AYE BAKER BY. BACKER
I'D DODD. DODD AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE TADO HI- TATO I
JONES I THINK. JONES I LEYVA.
MAIN MAN I'D NEWMAN A CHAU
ABODE ON A SHOW ABOUT A GUY HAN
HI CAN I. THE MEASURE HAS
TWELVE OF WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
WAITING ON ONE FINAL OFFER
COLLEAGUES. SENATOR UMBERG
STANDS BETWEEN US AND THE
CHUCKWAGON.
pTOLD YOUR COLLEAGUE WHO STAND
BETWEEN US AND THE CHUCKWAGON.
MY GOODNESS ZERO FINAL BILL
SENATE BILL FORTY NINE PLEASE
PROCEED SIR WELL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND I AM AWARE
THAT THERE IS PROBABLY NO MORE
DANGEROUS PLACE IN LIFE THAN
BETWEEN THE GROUP OF HUNGRY
FOLKS IN THE CHUCKWAGON BUT I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF THE PARTICULAR DANA.
SHOCKER FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
THEY'VE DONE ON. THE
DEVASTATING VISIT CALIFORNIA.
THESE FEES WOULD REPRESENT A
SIGNIFICANT COST TO SMALL
BUSINESSES PARTICULARLY AS
THEIR INCOMESHAVE BEEN CUT
SHORT BY THE EMERGENCY- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
ALLOWS FEES. TO- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BE WAIVED IF
THEY WERE CLOSE TO THE PANDEMIC
HOWEVER THIS WILL NOT MAKE UP
FOR FEES THAT WERE PAID IN THE
PAST AS BEFORE AND I WILL ALLOW
SMALL BUSINESSES TO OBTAIN
REFUNDS FOR THESE FEES THROUGH
A CREDIT ON THEIR TAX BILL-
THERE ARE SOME ISSUES THAT
STILL NEED TO BE WORKED OUT
SOME DEFINITIONS IT STILL NEED
TO BE CLARIFIED. AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO DO SO- BUT I URGE
YOU NOT ABLE TO. THANK YOU
SENATOR WILL NOW MOVE TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
BILL. WE WILL HEAR FROM ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NONE MOVED TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I SEE
NO WITNESSES THERE LET'S MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MISSED MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FORTY NINE WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO PRESS. ONE ZERO.
AND ONCE AGAIN LEAD THE GERMAN
PLEASE PRESS ONE TWO ZERO IF
YOU WISH TO CALL COMMON IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE FOURTEEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS THIS IS MATT SUTTON OF
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION AND THE COURTS- THE
BILL OF COURSE PROVIDES
EMPLOYEE RELIEF TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
EMPLOYERS. WHO ARE FORCED TO
SHUTTER THEIR OPERATIONS IN
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC- WHAT
YOU MAY OR MAY NOT KNOW IS THAT
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANTS AND OUR
OPERATIONS HAVE BEEN DICTATED
BY THE STATE CERTAINLY. BUT
SIXTY ONE DIFFERENT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT DICTATE. HOW
WE CAN OPERATE AND AT WHAT
LEVEL AND FOR MOST OF THE LAST
YEAR- INDOOR DINING IS BEEN
PROHIBITED AND IT LARGELY STILL
IS PROHIBITED AND MUCH OF THE
STATE SO. THIS BILL REPRESENTS
A MEASURE OF FAIRNESS AND JUST
GOOD GOVERNMENT- THE BILL.
LINES WITH PROTECTING PUBLIC
HEALTH. IS IT SEEKS TO THE
RELEASE- THE WARRANTED RELEASED
FOR THOSE THAT ATTACHED TO
COMPLYING WITH STATE AND LOCAL
HEALTH ORDERS. THANK YOU
SENATOR HAS HIGHER CENTER AMBER
CHRIS EARLY LEADERSHIP. ON THIS
ISSUE IN A THOUGHTFUL APPROACH-
IN THIS STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN ENSURING
CONTINUED- PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTIVE MEASURES WHILE ALSO-
ALLEVIATING THE EFFECTS
PRACTICE OF COLLECTING FEES
FROM BUSINESSES THAT ARE THAT
ARE SHOT BY THE GOVERNMENT.
THANKS SO MUCH IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. SURE THERE
pONE ADDITIONAL PERSON JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO LINE SIXTY SEVEN. YES
GOOD MORNING PRESS UNION FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. NEXT THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S
NOT FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM OPPOSITION WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION I
SEE NONE WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL FORTY
NINE I SEE NONE LET'S NOW MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THOSE ON THE LINE. WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU AGAIN MR
CHERRY IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE HAS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD JUST
CHECK THE LINE ONE MORE TIME TO
MAKE SURE WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL
WITNESSES BOTH IN SUPPORT AND
IN OPPOSITION AND THEN WE WILL
PROCEED. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THIS IS THE FINAL CALL IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT ON THIS BILL.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME IS THE FINAL CALL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. BUT YOU
SURE NO ONE IS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WE WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS. DR PAN FIRST UP
AGAIN. THANK YOU SIR CHAIR- ND
THE THIRD QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR AGAIN TO SHOOT THE BILL
JUST TO CLARIFY- SO- WHAT IS
THE SIZE OF THE CREDIT SO FOR
EXAMPLE ON CYSTIC IN MY
INFECTION- THIS IS CORRECT
APPLY DIRECTLY TO ME BUT A
PHYSICIAN'S PRACTICE HAD TO
CLOSE FOR. SAY SIX WEEKS TWO
MONTHS BECAUSE OF STAY AT HOME
ORDER- DEPOSITION HAS A MEDICAL
LICENSE. DID THEY GET CREDIT
FOR THEIR MEDICAL LICENSE FEE-
AND THEN I'LL GIVE ANOTHER
EXAMPLE SO YOU CAN JUST TACKLE
THEM ALL TIMES- YOU HAVE A
BUSINESS AS A BUSINESS LICENSE
FROM THEIR CITY- THEY HAD TO
CLOSE FOR A PERIOD OF TIME-
THEY MAY HAVE TO CLOSE THE
WHOLE YEAR BEFORE PORTION OF
TIME. DOES THIS IS THIS YOU GET
CREDIT FOR YOUR BUSINESS
LICENSE- FOR THE CITY AND THEN
IS THAT BECOME A STATE MANDATE
THAT THEREFORE WE IS THE STATE
HAVE TO REIMBURSE THE CITY FOR
SO. MANY TWO EXAMPLES THAT- YOU
CAN PERHAPS. CLARIFY HOW THIS
CREDIT WOULD WORK- THE- FIRST
QUESTION IS- IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE
TO PRACTICE. THEN YOU WOULD
GET. SOME OR ALL OF YOUR
LICENSE FEE THAT WOULD BE.
PROVIDED A TAX CREDIT THE
FOLLOWING YEAR- WITH RESPECT TO
BUSINESS LICENSE YES IT WOULD
BE A STATE MANDATED AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE CITY HAD NOT
BEEN PAID OR WHATEVER-
AUTHORIZING INSTITUTION- YES IT
WOULD. AND IT IN TERMS OF
OTHER. FOR EXAMPLE FEES IF YOU
HAD SOME SORT OF A- A FEE FOR.
NON INSPECTION- CONCERNING
CHEMICALS AND THAT KIND OF
THING SAME THING THERE YES THE
WHOLE PURPOSE IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT. YOU'RE NOT OPERATIONAL
YOU'RE NOT PAYING. THE STATE
FEES. THAT ONE WOULD NORMALLY
PAY IF YOU ARE. AFFECTED AND
JUST AGAIN FURTHER CLARIFY- SO
IF YOUR CLOTHES FOR THE DAY
PORTION OF THE YEAR BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW THINGS ARE- PEOPLE
COME. RESUMES OF IT IS IT IS
THE CREDIT AN ALLERGY TO FIND
THIS IS THE CREDIT AMOUNT THE I
GUESS THE PRO RATED SHARE OF
THE YEAR BECAUSE MEDICAL
LICENSES A TO YOU EVERY TWO
YEARS- BUSINESS. LICENSE AT
LEAST FOR TO SEE SACRAMENTO'S
ANNUAL SELLS YOUR CLOTHES FOR
LET'S SAY TWO MONTHS TO USE THE
CREDIT FOR THAT PRO REDUCED.
AMOUNT OF THAT FEE FOR THE TIME
YOUR CLOTHES OR DO YOU JUST
EXPLAIN MAYBE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW THE MECHANISM WORKS
FOR THIS TAX CREDIT YOU WOULD
PLAY FOR THE TAX CREDIT THEN
YOU WOULD CLAIM. BUT CERTAIN
TAX CREDIT ON A PRO RATED BASIS
SO. BEFORE YOU FILE YOUR. TAXES
DOCTOR PANEL BE HAPPY TO HELP.
MMHM THANKS VERY MUCH A
SEPARATE THANK YOU CENTERMAN.
THANK YOU I JUST TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR INTRODUCING THIS
BILL AND JUST WANT TO AND FIXED
THAT I'D LOVE TO THIS IN MY
EARLY STEP TO. THANK YOU SEVEN.
NEWMAN AS USUAL SO TANNER INTO
SO IN THE ARE TO MY COURSE.
THAT I VERY THE IS A VERY BILL
I COMMEND YOU. AS TO I THINK MS
SUTTON FOR THE- SAYS. THIRTY IT
IS MUCH MORE. HAVE BEEN DEVON
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY- I CHIU THE
SAN COMMITTEE ON CONDEMNING
MERGERS ARE NOW HEARING
ACTUALLY BE. THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY AND HOW IT'S BEEN
IMPACTED SO I WOULD.
RESPECTFULLY ASK AS WELL IF
THIS BILLS AMENDED ID ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR AND MAKE USE. OF NEWMAN
CENTER TO A BOOK. MISTER THANK
VERY MUCH THE AUTHOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS.
BILL FORWARD AS SOMEONE WHO.
WHOSE FATHER OWNED A COUPLE OF
RESTAURANTS IN THE AREA IT IS
VERY SYMPATHETIC TO THE- THE
CONDITION OF MANY OF OUR
RESTAURANTS IN THERE. AND WOULD
BE HAPPY TO- IF YOU'RE
ACCEPTING CALL OTHERS WOULD BE
HAPPY TO GO OUT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR. WE'LL DO. THIRD
WITH. TO BE CONTRARIAN SINCE
EVERYBODY SAYING HOW WONDERFUL
IT IS I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
KNOW- I'M I'M NO FAN OF MEANS
TESTING BUT THIS BILL DOESN'T
SAY HOW BIG THE COMPANY HAS TO
BE HOW MANY EMPLOYEES THEY HAVE
TO HAVEHOW MANY- HOW LONG THEY
WOULD HAVE HAD TO BE A CLOSE
NONE OF THAT SO- IS THERE IS
THERE ANY THOUGHT INTO THAT OR
IS IT. COME ONE COME ALL IT
WOULD BE PRO RATED BASED ON THE
TIME THAT YOU WOULD BE CLOSE SO
FOR EXAMPLE TO USE CENTER PANS-
QUESTION IS THAT IF YOUR
CLOTHES FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR THE
TAX CREDIT THAT YOU WOULD APPLY
FOR YOU WOULD CLEAN THE ENTIRE
YEAR YOUR CLOTHES REPORT SHE'D
ONLY CLAIM A PORTION OF IT- IT
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO-
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE SIZE OF
COMPANIES IT IS DIRECTED
TOWARDS SMALL BUSINESSES- SMALL
BUSINESSES FOR EXAMPLE A
RESTAURANT WITH A LIQUOR
LICENSE OR A LICENSE TO SELL
LIQUOR. THAT COULD BE VERY
EXPENSIVE PART OF THEIR
OPERATING COSTS- QUERY WE CAN
WE CAN LOOK AT IT IS TO IS TO
OTHER BUSINESSES BUT IT IS
GEARED TO FOCUS ON SMALL
BUSINESSES IN. PARTICULAR
RESTAURANTS AND BARS. CORRECT
AND IT'S GETS GEARED TOWARDS.
BUT DOESN'T OF IT IN JUST. IT
IS NOT CURRENTLY TO OKAY THANKS
SOME ONE LOOK THE- THANK. THANK
YOU SAID EGGMAN. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE FEDERAL BURKE GREAT
JOB WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU FOR THOSE QUESTIONS
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
SUGGESTIONS WITH RESPECT TO-
FURTHER REFINING AND DEFINING
THE BILL ARJUN IDLE. MEMBERS IS
THERE A MOTION SOME OF TO MOVE
IT. OKAY OOPS SPOKE FIRST-
TULLOW. THANK YOU SIR HELLO
CENTER TYLER WAS MOVED TO FILL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
NUMBERS PLEASE MAKE SURE TO
HAVE YOUR MICROPHONE ON FILE
ITEM NINE SENATE BILL FORTY
NINE MEMBERS GIVE THE PASS AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE ROSS.
ROSS AYE MELENDEZ AYE MELENDEZ
AYE ARCHULETA ON VIRGIL OUT I'D
BE FINE. EIGHT FIVE BAKER.
BAKER I DAHLE. DODD AYE A-
EGGMAN AYE HER TADO NINE FOR
TADO I'D- JONES I LEAVE HI
LEAVE A I'D BEEN ON MAN I
NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE ACCIONES
FIVE IT SHOWED IPO. CAN I.
MEMBERS OF THE BILL HAS
FOURTEEN VOTES AND THAT BILL
IS- I DON'T. LET'S GO AHEAD AND
OPEN THE ROLE AND CLOSE OUT
BILLS. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FILE ITEMS Q. FOR. AND FEATS
HER TADO HI HURTADO I'D JONES
HI JONES I. THE BILL HAS
FOURTEEN VOTERS THAT BILLS OUT.
YEAH YEARS LATER THAN ME ALL.
FILE ITEM ONE SB THREE OH FOUR
ARCHULETA. BACKER EGGMAN LEYVA.
MANY NEWMAN PAN. EIGHT THE BILL
HAS EIGHT VOTES THE BILL IS OUT.
WITH FILE ITEM FIVE SB FIVE
FOUR FOUR LAYERED BEATS. HER
TADO HIGH- TADO II THE BILL HAS
THIRTEEN VOTES THE BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM SEVEN SB THREE SIX
TWO NEWMAN. HER TADO. A SHOW
ABOUT. THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES
THE BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM
THREE SB FOUR THIRTY BORJAS
LEYVA. NEWMAN THE BILL HAS
TWELVE VOTES THE BILL IS OUT.
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA
TODAY THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFIED TODAY.
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE TO DO SO. YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE CERTAINLY
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AGAIN WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. WE HAVE INCLUDED
THE AGENDAS I NOTED THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IS ADJOURNED.